recording though yeah must beam alikum
guys how you doing listen you you're
going to see a fantastic podcast right
now but before you do so we want to
really urge you to give money to charity
this Ramadan and we're doing Food Packs
in all of the deprived areas and places
like Somalia and places like Pakistan
and places like Afghanistan and Morocco
so make sure you click the link below
sneo do you want to say anything about
this of course Zak is a very important
part of being a Muslim if you're not a
Muslim this is going to feed people
right now now I think it's very
important right now that you give your
money away it's going to cleanse your
your mind and cleanse your wealth
because there's a lot of Haram money
that we're making so give some money
away feed some people and you you'll
feel better and the people you're
feeding will definitely feel better Al
you want to say something about that no
I say about the prophet P from him said
that s will never make you poor isan for
you it's a witness for you will get in
the way of Calamity and he said cure
your sick with s yeah this is what we
believe in so brother sisters uh give
whatever you can
yeah Char doesn't decrease from your
weth and uh especially with what we're
seeing around the world the brothers and
sisters are definitely need of our
support and if Allah has blessed you
then share the wells
D um yeah I agree with
all the link below nobody's went broke
giving money away for charity nobody's
ever gone bro giving money to charity
said exactly never make you poor all
right take a link below
poverty is one of the greatest
indicators for Crime because it makes
crime a rational choice if you think if
you really think about if someone's not
making that much money they're more
likely to engage in crime now if you
look at the Historical of what like the
historical proc of what happened in the
United Kingdom for example after World
War II A lot of people came into the
country from the ex colonies to rebuild
the country so there were blue color
workers they were workingclass people
and they continued being work class so
the United
Kingdom a lot of the wolen people in the
community they're not middle class or
upper class they're work class they're
poor people they they're taking for
example benefits from the state they're
welfare they're on Council they're
homeless they you know they're claiming
better these kind of things in America
you've got the same demographic in in
California cuz when I went to California
I started read like this is a bit of a
culture shock cuz you have pakistanis
like I Sacramento I spent time in LA and
stuff places but mostly the sacramental
and I realized that the kind of
pakistanis you got there and South
Asians
are rich rich to say to say it crudely
right rich people middle class out of
class and that's because America decided
when they were bringing people in to
have people who have a certain caliber
educational caliber we're going to have
doctors we're going to have this
Engineers we're going to have this they
England didn't think like that England
in fact England had the OB it strategy
they just needed to get blue color
workers in so yes it's true if you
compare for example so America kind of
handpicked the people that they wanted
it was a different context completely
they because think about it America
wasn't actually physically destroyed by
the war whereas England was England was
attacked physically by by Germany in
that World War 2 America was far away
from it they got involved in the world
but they didn't get they were untouched
only Pearl Hara and that's not really
anything you know to be to count to be
honest with you compared to what
happened in Europe so as a result you're
seeing these kind of things like you
you'll find that most countries in
Europe I'll take some
yes most countries in Europe so France
has a has a big intake of um algerians
of of Moroccans mostly algerians Belgium
the same thing and they're all EX
colonies and the first of all they're
work class the same story work class so
you'll find poty but also you'll find
crime among
groups um but you also find resentment
because really these are ex people that
are pocorn lives like in the Algerian
Cas the people K so they don't have a
really favorable attitude towards the
French so you have a two-way resent it's
all very interesting but what I'm trying
to say is that while you while I went to
South Africa for example the Indians
there were very rich they were very rich
and they were very like were they Hindu
or Muslim Muslim yeah obviously the
Hindus are as well but like the ones I
saw that were Muslim were very rich
Muslim very rich so it really depends on
the context you'll find every part of
whether it's the Western World or
whether it's Africa or South Africa
whatever it is you'll find minority
Muslims operating in a slightly
different way because of I would say the
main factor is social plus that's my
view it's not race it's not religion
it's actually social BL that's why
you'll find white people if they're in a
deprived area in London they're more
likely to commit crimes
I used to work in Essex and it's kind of
P I used to work here and it was a
working class you know uh white people
that were committing crimes and all kind
of things things it's because it's not
because of their race I mean they would
jump and say it's because your race or
jump and say it's because your religion
we say it's because it becomes a
rational choice for you to do that right
because you don't have money and so it
makes sense to take high risks and high
rules do you believe in race realism at
all no you don't think IQ is ingrained
to your race whatsoever I don't agree
with this that's
it's a very unfortunate you know belief
system I think it's wrong so so why do
you think Asians score so high on IQ
because of the
culture it's not not just IQ the
following yeah why if it's not just
Asians look at Chinese people Chinese
people and Indian people they do very
well um powerful pound they do very very
well like in University saintes
objectively like if you look at
statistically depending on subject but
Chinese people they do very well
especially like economics I how but they
do very well what is it about Chinese
culture needs to be asked what is it
about Indian culture I think it to do
with pressure bro this the kind of
pressure they put I I recently looked at
um statistics of this year in the United
Kingdom um and the government the United
Kingdom government put them out for gc's
which is it's like the SATs right right
before the right before the AL um and
the third group was bangladeshis I was
very very surprised by SE yeah so if if
race rism was true then what's going on
because the thing is what's in common
between a bangi or Indian and a Chinese
what's I mean usually those who espouse
race realism they connect to the white
genene but the Chinese is far away from
being a white white guy s to say and
Indian is far away from being a white in
fact he's not a white guy at all so do
you know what I mean
[Laughter]
because Chinese
white but we were just talking in the
car funny enough we're talking about in
sports though I do believe in certain
races have certain advant in the sport I
know it's a controversial idea you you
know but if in the last 50 years how
many how many white men have Run 100
mile 100 met got got a gold medal for
thats none none not even that many none
zero the answer is zero bro imagine that
imagine the statistic that
says in 100 meter I think the last 30 or
50 years no white man has ever won that
so you could say there are certain
things that favor you know West West
African genetics West AF or east African
like for example the long distance
Runners well they're fast but they're
long distance so why are physical
attributes why is that correlate with
race but you're saying that something
like IQ is not correlate race the thing
is IQ test I'm not convinced by
it as a as a process of determining
who's more clever and who's not more
clever who's more loable who's more
loable I'm not convinced by the it's not
a good metric of intelligence I'm say
it's not a good measure it could be a
good measure because they have a they
have a very like they have logical
aspect they have grammatical aspect they
that but they haven't convinced me in
saying that this is the gold standard of
of explaining human intelligence
bringing it to Islam Indians are taking
over in terms of becoming billionaires
and I want to I want to understand what
you think about the difference between
Indian Muslims and 100% you know blood
this yeah why are Indians taking over um
and every F like it if you look at um
the amount of billionaires and Tech
Industries it's so many Indians are
taking over that a lot of time people
like to talk about the Jewish influence
and and money but Indians are are doing
really well are they Muslim or are they
Hindu what's the difference
so the thing with whether it's zionists
or whether it's um Hindus they have an
in innate contradiction within their
faith which is that you can be an
atheist you can still be a Hindu you can
be an atheist but you can still be a Jew
so the fact that there's such a big
flexibility having such a big
flexibility allows you to adapt more
than say s say someone like a Muslim who
has set criteria who has you know more
boundaries and all kind of demarcations
so Hindus can be put in any surrounding
any kind of thing and they can adapt
their religion is very flexible for
example they believe one God but they
believe in a thousand gods they they
believe that the tree is God but they
believe that the tree is not God they
believe that there is no God but they
believe there's 100 Gods so there this
because we have we have these
conversation you're laughing but it's
true yeah yeah it's because we have
conversations whether it's on live
stream
whether it's at Speakers Corner whether
we see the content and you will
genuinely he Hindus you will hear Jewish
people I came across a Jewish atheist
and the guy said yeah I'm a Jewish
atheist how that works then do you start
playing with semantics yeah we can do
this a Jewish person they have certain
beliefs however some of them some of
them you know they will say you know
what belief is they they start becoming
very perennialist which is oh yeah the
religions it's fine we do this and we
put this forward and we do like this so
for them there's a great deal of
flexibility you won see for example the
CEO of alphabet for um Google is that an
Indian that's an Indian yeah is that a
Hindu it's uh yeah cleans to be in Hindu
but what type of Hindu does he pray does
he do multi Hindu or clean yeah is that
what did you say that multi Puja what's
that multi Puja is idol worship but they
believe that Idol worship is different
to say a p pagans idol worship like they
believe that the essence or part of God
actually resides in the idol this is
what they did recently in India as well
there's an inauguration ceremony where
you create an idol but then you have to
do a ceremony that a part of God goes in
there and it becomes a miti so for them
bro you can put a miti in a workplace
you can put a miti at home you can pray
at 3:00 in the morning you pray 8:00 in
the evening you can pray after one week
so their stringent nature is not as as
stringent as say Muslims um for them
it's it's very flexible bro you can eat
meat but then you don't have to eat meat
there's so much flexibility even when
within their own religion and when
there's so much flexibility and
everything is unclear like there's who
who do you worship ah I I worship the
Consciousness what's Consciousness are
you conscious yeah so technically I'm
God as well yeah what about Brahma yeah
he's God as well he's the the Creator
God you know what I mean so when you've
got so many different um views oh yeah
you just meditate you have your own
relationship with God what does that
mean having your own relationship I
don't know what how are you are you an
expert on Hinduism cuz I've looked into
it recently um I've got like a Hindi
Channel as well I translate my videos
not only that for example when it comes
to uh interest like the Jewish people
they they they contr interest to the
Gentiles or the go which is US yeah yeah
but they can't try to interest within
themselves we as Muslim Muslims we don't
exploit it's a form of exploitation the
interest form of exploitation yes so um
we don't say Muslim or non-muslim we
exactly so to us it's like Muslim not
Muslim you're not to do interest because
interest is wage of war against Allah
and his messenger so there are certain
things we can't do where we cannot go
and exploit others and again I'm not
seeing only Jewish people do that what
I'm seeing is that don't be anti-semitic
in their belief system that's true they
allowed to tr interest to others and not
among as themselves so there are certain
things that as Muslims we cannot do
because to us this important to obey God
and not to take the rights of others
because in Islam taking the rights of
others is very severe that's why the
prophet peace be upon him he would
refuse to do the burial uh prayer for an
individual who owed money to somebody so
with us is so to if you think about it
when somebody commits a sin there's
three conditions number one you stop the
sin you hate the sin and you try not to
go back to the sin but there's a fourth
condition if you wrong the right of
someone so if I wronged hijab it's not
just enough for me to ask for repentance
but I have to ask for him to forgive me
if I owe my debt I have to pay that debt
you know so that's why it's very very
important Islam takes great importance
even before you enter parad there's a
specific place where you will be asked
if I let's say me and PAB we F out you
know there will be that would be the
time where we would in reconcile or ask
for each other's rights so so that's why
I believe it plays a big great thing in
economics when it comes to maybe why
Muslims are not doing as much and also
yeah and sadly yeah Muslim we do have to
take accountability how many Muslims
want to be scientists they don't they're
too immersed and that's why the prophet
peace people want prophesies because
Allah would take put the love of the
world into your hearts and take the fear
of your enemies from their hearts so why
and and this was a time when the the
prophet said Nations will come together
how we are eating food against you and
the and the companion said oh is it
because we will be small in numbers he
said rather you'll be great in number
that's right and that's exactly the time
we're living in why because we have
turned our back to our religion if we
followed our religion cuz we are too
immersed in the world money money this
Fame that Etc you're you're a Muslim I
came to Islam 11 years ago sure I used
that's what my lifestyle used to be
money cars girls what I drive what I do
who thinks what told me I was I was a
slave to society my God was my God was
the opposite gender gu the cars that I
drive the money that I make that's what
Allah says in the Quran have we seen the
one who has multiple Masters compared to
the one who has one I found my freedom
when I enslaved myself to Allah because
I'm already like like was I was asking
the philosopher who said man is born
free free but every everyone chains but
chained in Chains everywhere and that is
that is our usle Islam has come to free
us from the worship to the creation to
the Creator because all of us if you
like it or not you're influenced you're
influenced by one thing or another
nobody comes and says to me like I speak
about these girls andless say for
example wearing 8 in heels Inus 5° minus
SC and I'm thinking are you telling me
you willingly wake up and spend 2 and a
half hours to do makeup where heels that
hurt your anle that you need to walk
bare for and on the pavement and you and
you're wearing a minus that's free in
Gold you don't you are influenced you
are subconsciously influenced Islam has
come to free from the influence of the D
to the Creator so there's many elements
of just just I believe might take can I
ask you cuz I don't know almost any
other reverse from the people that in
our Circle Warner has growing up with
Islam muhamad grew up with Islam you
definitely grew up with Islam what was
it like to to rever and I'm wondering
for the RS that are watching the stream
right now uh what was the reception like
uh with your family with my family I've
always told my story about my dad my mom
like my family members my background I
come from they're very hostile towards
Islam they don't like Islam like like
with what's what what's the religion is
your background so the thing is my dad's
an atheist my dad's side and my mom's
side they have aloise so they're like a
set of Shia but if you look into the
belief system I've come across Alo who
say I'm an atheist Al I'm like what you
mean you're an atheist Al like so it's
it's it's there's no belief system there
so to me like my dad was very very large
he would say the thing that I hate the
most has been born into my family so
he's talking about me so he's that the
thing that I hate the most has come out
my it's not good no he hates it he like
he hates it not that my dad is a bad
person but to him he's that this is the
thing that I despise the most and now my
son has ended up out of all religions
going and found this religion so to him
he he really dislikes it but he's he's a
bit better know man he's a bit better
now how do you think ravers should
introduce Islam to their family like
right now I wouldn't say I'm jealous but
being uh it's the month of Ramadan and
seeing everybody the the family aspect
and the Brotherhood andever even moose
is saying that he doesn't want to travel
too much because like it's how important
it is to spend ifar with your family
obviously my family none of them are
Muslim same same like I'm I'm in the
same both so when you could talk about
jealousy there's two types of jealousy
there's good jealousy and bad jealousy
so the jealousy you want is something
that you want what others have for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
as long as the bad type of jealousy is
that you want what an individual has
taken away from them so what you have is
is there's nothing wrong with it because
you're saying I would like the same same
for myself and that's no human nature so
there's nothing wrong with it just so
you know cuz I know sometimes we use the
word jealousy comes with a connotation
of it's negative no in Islam you ask
Allah Allah I would like from that for
myself one day and that's why in when
you get married and you have kids in may
Allah give you that you you taste like
and for myself obviously it's hard
because your family don't celebrate like
they don't fast uh when you come home
you know there's food Etc so yeah it's
it's it's it's it's so how do we first
yeah how do we introduce Islam to our
family you know the how do we show them
the good parts of that
answer the question the biggest mistake
the biggest mistake I made in my life
was Meet
thisan no I'm Jing it was one of the
best thing to me brother this is for you
champ champ are you pleased you're
speaking to the wrong champ okay Champs
that's what my
wife that's the she should use so are
you pleased so when it comes to this
actually thank you bro the biggest the
biggest mistake we make as new Muslims
is the follow we're passionate we're
zealous we we you know when you when
you've been in darkness and there's just
a bit of sunlight you just like oh my
gosh what is that so when we come to
Islam when we are so rust that's why you
see rewards they they holding the Islam
back with their dear life because
they've seen the ugly side of life so
when you seen the ugly side of life when
you come and you know see like it's like
when you're married to a evil woman and
when you come and marry someone that's
decent bro you're like you know what
this woman I have to hold on my headb so
the thing is what happens when we come
from Islam we think we're passionate
everything's Haram the prophet P him
said I came for nothing but to perfect
good character yeah and this is
something we lack greatly we want people
to see Islam in us not let them hear
from us like Z list yet he call the
Quran but let people see Islam in you so
for me with my dad for example it would
be very harsh in there was a time where
he slapped me he about to
that
so was that your
[Laughter]
ugly
Bo yeah by the way view you need to get
used to all hum hij insult to my
[Laughter]
genetics you JS you have to put me down
so I didn't know you were friends before
this who me and him yes I just assume
that everybody in the da Ser has I
didn't know I didn't know you guys do
each other three I
seen yeah we we are a friends yeah so in
the UK most of us M has pretty much met
with each other the beef correct me if
I'm wrong he's very little it's only
with
one those guys
are but that's what I hear to name
them usually it's a group of brothers
that have issue with everybody on the
other side but yeah the the way you
conduct yourself you know it's very
important cuz I can remember once my dad
I was on the other side of the room and
Bin ladin came out on the TV yeah and
then my dad was like come here come here
he's like look your friends on
TV I you see he's at Comic house I was
what happened I was like he's going to
take a Shah goes come come
look that's actually perfect I want to
ask you about that Muhammad a
job about J there was a big Uprising on
on Tik Tok I'm sure you've seen about
people learning about Osama Bin Laden
and oh yeah the
book The Letter um and obviously there's
some conspiracy theories about what
really happened in 911 do you think that
um did they lie about Osama Bin Laden is
every was the truth because in America
we hated him John Cena he got on TV and
he celebrated at WWE saying we killed
Osama Bin Laden everybody clapped and
now uh John Cena is getting naked in
front of the Grammys and everybody kind
of seeing the truth about these people
oh my but did me to go naked I those uh
now that's real that's real yeah in the
front of the the Oscars or whatever
while accepting an award so it's like
should we really believe this because
that was the part of the brainwashing
for a long time that was part of the
islamophobia and I think um the the
demonization of wasam lot fed into a lot
of people's heads about about Islam so
but if you read Bin Laden's fatwa in in
he had two fatwas one in
98 that fat is a religious ruling or
verdict that's given he done one in 98
and he done one directly or a few
after um there's no there's no by the
way you're doomed yeah if you read what
he said in this he said the main reason
one of the main reasons he gives for
doing for for being at war with America
is the palestin issue he says that
you're killing our Innocents and we
should be since you're killing our
Innocents we can kill your innocence
simple as that and I for an i he's
basically that's his idea now
islamically speaking that's incorrect
jump so to to be clear no scholar of
Islam has ever said this before okay for
example ABD who is a classical scholar
of the 15th century and this is before
liberalism before anything he said there
is consensus on the fact consensus on
the fact that you can't kill women and
children in war that's that is a view
that I follow yeah which is according to
the consensus
view however isn't it interesting that
what usan bin ladin is doing or saying
or his philosophy is is actually is more
moderate than what we seeing in Israel
it's way more moderate cuz he the way he
sees it is you kill one of our Innocents
we kill one of your innocence the way
Israel sees it is you kill one of our
Innocents yeah we kill 5,000 so if
you're sort of upset about B Laden
because he killed 3,000 people in more
bro 911 people died 3,000 right yeah
okay if 3,000 people's a problem what is
30,000 unless you want to tell me
American blood is more important than
inan blood that's exactly what it is
yeah so if white blood sounds more if
you see a picture of bad and you SE it
to an average American he'll feel very
angry and I'm not telling him you
shouldn't feel that feeling so if that
same American now is going to be
indifferent yeah that average American
to what's going on in Palestine and
30,000 which is times 10 we've got 10
911s
happening using that as a metric of
death yeah what are you talking about
bro we're talking about 10 911s
10 9 11s and and that's just the recent
Escapade of the Israelis and there we
have genocidal intent they're they're
justifying all this kind of stuff but
people now start to wake up to the fact
not that bad was right all along and
this and that it's not that severe we're
not going that far but what we're saying
is that if you found that this was
egregious then what the hell is this
with Israel what the hell is this well
it's 10 times the amount of death the
mop and yeah it's 10 times the amount of
death all the justification in the world
and it's not even one for one bad's
reasoning was more moderate than nanyu
because bad was saying you killed one of
our innocence we're going to kill yours
I say that's wrong and that's and that's
wrong islamically it's wrong but Nyah is
saying even though he doesn't want to
say it like this but some of his um her
dog say something similar which is that
everyone's responsible everyone in Gaza
is responsible the whole thing he said
why call to the Old Testament he said
that malachit he calls them mikit yeah
you know the story about meites so who
is more of the two
be honest about the situation so the to
am is basically I don't if it's Hebrew
15 vers 2 a different verse here but
it's basically talking about First
Samuels 1 Samuel 15: so so yeah exactly
go it's they literally just think about
this yeah the far right Tommy Robinson
and his light yeah the inell the bastard
yeah from worship this so the thing is
this they will come and say Isis Isis is
doing a TR TR it's quot in the Quran qu
in the Quran and we would come and say
no way in the Quran does it tell us to
go and kill innocent people yeah no way
where so they would use this whole card
of Isis now the far right yeah with this
whole issue if you think about it you've
now got clear cuz when Isis was doing
their Madness you had your late Muslim
men Muslim public working the 95
whatever it is condemning it you had
public speakers like us condemning it
you had the imams condemning it you had
the Muslim worlders condemning it but
now look at what Israel is doing what
Israel is doing they are outright
propagating it with quoting their old
scripture which is the first Samuel 15:2
which said go to am and kill men women
children babies
donkeys the donkey done there they go
and kill everybody and keep the young
and keep them for so what I'm seeing is
this how is it that they are directly
quoting from the scripture and not only
are they quoting it but they carrying
out the atrocities by King men with to
children and if you notice this very
carefully bro that's right it's not just
MPS if you saw my video when speak S I
was speaking to this Zionist just some
lady random lady here and she clearly
said I do not believe that Palestinian
kids are innocent out right can you
imagine a Muslim woman in a hijab saying
I don't believe what Isis is doing the
kids that they killing They're Not
Innocent bro they'll be I'll be in go B
bro if I was to say such a statement but
they casually are saying we should kill
more babies they are mocking them and
you cannot make this stuff up that's why
we want I than Israel we could have not
done it without them bro if I had a
billion pound Bud a billion pound budget
I would have never orchestrated getting
idea of soldiers to say what they say
they do it for free on camera so we just
we just ask Allah and Allah's
humiliating them and showing their
reality because the whole public opinion
has changed so do you think they
purposely didn't translate The Works of
os Bin Laden so that we would
misunderstand and that they could paint
him in a bad light yeah there also
history of them to be honest they don't
even they even publicize his actual
fatalism what he said they just make AR
about him the average American have not
heard what they have no idea there are
stand explanations yeah his explanation
if an American said it with a as a white
American said the same thing after the
equivalent of uh whatever it is that he
American disaster happened by hands off
he thinks has happened to was his
initial complain was about Palestine if
you look at what's happened it is that
America is allying with Palestine so if
uh Iran had allied with one of America's
enemies and then uh such and such a
thing happened the same thing you to
reverse it and then an american guy said
what is saying is that you kill going to
kill the kill I don't think it'll be
that contral I think that would be
allowed I think the culture would allow
that bro I'm not all lie to you I think
we have
effectively a thousand of in America so
we have a million of them Israel do you
know say culture would allow that we've
seen that the culture allows that they
don't mind inoc people can kill so long
it's not their innocent that's what we
found yeah yeah soan how do we fix that
sort of image with Islam because they've
done a good job in the past 20 years of
demonizing Islam by using figures like
Osama Bin Laden's and this represent
what he believed in and make his they
seem like it's it's a violent religion
when it's really very peaceful even I
had struggles so before I became a
Muslim uh with that sort of programming
frally brother it's important to
understand that Islam is always going to
be seen as a bad guy yeah reason being
because Islam goes against the very
things that this Society rests upon for
example I was looking at the um alcohol
industry yeah which is A1 and5 trillion
dollar industry yeah Islam comes along
and says alcohol is forbidden yeah but
what about the Old Testament the
assembly the new test no it's forbidden
there's no ifs or no buts gambling a
trillion dollar industry in itself Islam
comes along says no that's forbidden
yeah alcohol forbidden gambling
forbidden drugs is half a trillion
dollar industry nope forbidden the mujah
or the Taliban came in before the
Americans were making all this money of
the OPM Taliban come in the Opium yeah
whatever you might think about them but
cut enough drugs which nagua you know
the US were actually utilizing cocaine
when it came to the Nicaragua and the
sanded easers before it was already
exposed but here no no drugs the sex
industry again worth half a trillion
dollars right again Islam comes along
and says Nope Haram the did a good job
of of outlawing uh poppy in in
Afghanistan yeah that's what I'm saying
problem completely yeah that's where the
PO opium comes from isn't it so Islam
comes along with categorical statements
cutting at the root
of these cabal these individuals that
make money of people's miseries for
example bro just take industry sorry
just take interest now interest us yeah
Usery now this is something which the
world pretty pretty much relies upon but
if you just break down what interest is
slavery it's slavery but also it not
only promotes extravagance but what it
does is it harm the economy yeah now how
does it harm the economy someone that's
borrowing something now he's been given
interest he has to retract he can't
spend as much yeah so now the person
that he's buying from he's selling
selling less stuff then the person that
supplied him then the farmer that
supplied him has not going effect as
Muslims we come along and say so this
helps the economy and it reduces
extravagance as well so you will see
within the inbuilt systems of Islam
extravagance
this isn't this isn't extravagant this
is this is love extravagant people in
the chat are saying all Muslims do is
eat I just do remind you guys it's
Ramadan we did not eat all day long this
is anyone want this and this is thanks
to the brother's contact he obviously
wants to there's no more
space yeah so bro even when we look at
history the small ones can I have one
a few
res one more
this even when it comes
to like anyone who's in control and
using power divide and Ru has always
been the be all and end all for example
if you look in history there is there
was an actual group called The Bavarian
Illuminati not the Illuminati the
Bavarian Illuminati they were
scapegoated after them came the
Catholics after them came the blacks
after them came the this the that now
it's just the turn of the Muslims one of
my neighbors he's black and he's not a
Muslim but he just laughs with me and he
says you know now it's just your turn
before there was our turn now it's just
your turn the Buck has been passed on
but the buck will stay with us because
all the powers that be they're saying
this is this is a man this is a no there
is no man there is no woman they're
trying to change the reality from in
front of you there is no right there is
no wrong there's no objective morality
sneo there's nothing there's no right or
wrong some doing a surgery is the same
as somebody scratching his ass to put it
frankly so when there's no morality when
interest is okay as long as you're
making money as long as you're helping
and individualism it's fine you know as
long as you don't hurt somebody else
what does hurt somebody else mean ah it
doesn't matter we'll talk about that
later hey look at this guy there's a
boxing fight going on oh oh there's a
cricket match going oh there's a
football what that oh netflix1
billion for a Star Wars series oh what's
that one billion yeah 1 billion that was
the budget so when these sorts of
budgets are given there but when you
look at what way spending it's not
comparable so Islam will always be a
threat to them because even as speakers
cor you you and I we were there today
when you when you spoke to Jewish people
they do not claim their book is
preserved they do not even profess that
that is the same book that was there
before Christians they do not profess
that Hindus don't profess that Muslims
do right Muslims profess it's the same
exact book we can prove we have
manuscripts we have a live language we
have people that memorize it from cover
to cover on this table I will recite
something from the Quran I will make a
mistake three four brothers will be
that's wrong but if you do that with the
New Testament non-existent no one will
know bro so with Islam because it's
preserved because it's the last line of
defense no Prophet to come after Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him so Sall Ali
wasallam so that Islam is always going
to be a threat to them it's always going
to be a threat to the economy it's going
to be a threat to the ideological
manipulation because now Islam is the
last defense you mentioned and it's the
Sol that's why they see it as a threat
because it's it's a solution to all
these modern slavery problems absolutely
but it's funny The Speaker's Corner I
think it strengthened my faith even
though it's not good da over there I'm
sure you guys enjoy for the the mental
sparring aspect of it which one of my
videos led to the shahada
[Laughter]
did you see how there was
a I was trying to
remember trying to recall which I ask I
so who are the great speakers that you
listen to this La I sat back and wait
[Laughter]
for but you know this is actually very
interesting cuz I the other day maybe
this is like U seven or eight days ago I
reread um a book a classic by Samuel
hun Clash
civilization it's a very it's it's a
very important work actually um it's a
very important work I my
undergraduate degree I I went through
that book cuz it was like a pop it was a
very important book um and I just reread
it again because a lot of what's
Happening Now the culture Clash I I
wanted to kind of revisit it and the
Theses of the book Samuel P hton he
wrote this
1998 uh article in in a in a journal
called Foreign
Affairs and in it what he does is that
he divides the World Civilization to
seven he says the world is effectively
seven
civilizations and he he tells you what
they are he says it's a western
civilization it's to Orthodox
civilization like Russian Orthodox
Eastern Orthodox he says it's the
African I don't know why he says that
because that's that's a mistake I think
he says it's the Africans civilization
there's one African there's not I think
he isans by like tribal African which
wherever that
is um and then he says the Japanese he
makes that into a civilization by itself
the Indian
civilization I think he makes that into
a civilization
itself like Hindu or something and then
the Islamic China andan not Indian I
don't think I don't think because China
and then the last one is the the Islamic
civilization and effectively what he's
the thesis of this book is that in the
end of times we're moving towards a
clash a culture clash between different
civilizations and The Clash is most
likely to happen effectively between the
west and Islam that's his thesis when
was his written this 1997 98 he died in
2001 May 2002 they killed him no no I
don't think they he was no he was an
advisor to the G he he was an advisor to
G so he in the back in the the end of
his book he actually gave advice to US
government of how to uh destroy the
Islamic langage he did in a such a way
he said you have to effectively he just
said you have to divide divide and
conquer he said you have to divide them
create create dis Unity among them which
is you know we're seeing that you know
if you see how the Muslim world is is
even M mapped out now it's it's like
that but the point is is that it's very
interesting okay if you look at the
other civilizations right China and
Russia the two two biggest um threats
military threats and economic threats
right now right both of them they don't
have a key thing and this is something
that hunted key what do you mean a key
thing I'll tell you what the key thing
is the missing recipe the missing a
missing thing so China has effectively
adopted communism in the past ma with
MAO they were Communists now they're
just capitalists or he calls it the
confucianist civilization they don't
really have an expansionist policy they
don't have an ideology an idea that they
can expand to the rest of the world
Manifest Destiny yeah they don't have
the idea of a manifest destiny right and
Russia the same thing really there's
only little differences between the
Russian
civilization and the western
civilization they really believe in the
same religion and Christianity orever
what was the difference it's an
authoritarian regime it's not there's
nothing there that you can export to the
rest of the world Islam is the only
civilization which has the potential to
expand to export its
ideas and to overtake the liberal World
Order and that's why I think he focused
on Islam he really focused on it he was
worried of Islam the most because
although Russia and China from look from
that perspective there are two huge
Powers Russia less so now I mean
militarily China is really growing I
mean the Americans are very scared of
China but the chin the Chinese the
Chinese can't really overtake America
let's be honest I mean can the can the
Chinese go in and overtake America like
militarily very difficult very difficult
honestly very difficult uh number one
number two what are they going to if
they do let's let's do a thought
experiment let's say they overtake the
world the Chinese will take the world
yeah what they going bring what are they
going to what are they going to bring to
the table what what are you now
exporting confusion ISM you don't they
don't care about export they've never
been expansionists like that China have
always cared about their own kind of
thing they don't care about they know
Islam is a TI that's what they worried
about that we have a system which
replaces their system and it's
intelligible it's it's got um rituals
attached to it it's got religion
attached to it it's got World viw
attached to it that's why they have to
attack Islam role because I think that
all following the line people like
Bernard Lewis who wrote a book called
what went RW with a slam uh Samuel P
Huntington and there was a guy who is
the student of under F Fay Francis f
yeah Japanese guy know yeah end of
History end of history but he had the
idea that that's it the West is won and
that's it you know nothing needs to be
done
first they do he would agree right they
they listen to these guys they I think
that the administrations listen to these
guys they don't listen to the liberalist
when it comes to foreign policy and
stuff they listen to these kinds of guys
and I think that what you're seeing with
the Coalition of the the media and the
uh and the governments against Islam is
because they know if Islam unites and it
grows it becomes a an immediate
Challenger and competitor to their world
order so this is expected if I was the
American put it this way if I was the
Americans and I believed in what they
believe I would tell them exactly what
Sam P Huntington told divide these guys
if these guys come together it's it's
it's a nightmare for all of us so what
is the Chinese government what is the
CCB doing to the Muslims right now I
hear a lot of different it's hard to
find a real information about what's
going on over
there we've interviewed people while
it's pretty clear I mean firstand
witness testimonies that they are
putting them in these hand of
concentration camps they're trying to
change the of authoritarian regime they
consider the the turkic Muslims easn
East uh East tur turkistan they consider
them to be a threat because they they
have a different identity so they want
to try and amalgamate them to the
culture they trying to assimilate them
to the culture and they try to do by
force because Islam is a very strong
culture so the way to they're trying to
erase it is they're trying to put people
in different
places put kids in compulsory education
sep mother from Child we've seen all
these
things but exactly but it's China so
they they're pretty strong at being able
to say to God
themselves from criticism to to to do it
under surveillance of certain place and
so you won't be able to see it like
social media like what you see in
Palestine that's the differ who's going
to who's going to they're not going to
allow that and and who can criticize
them they don't have they don't have the
sorry they don't have the equivalent of
Hamas yeah they don't have that they
they you know they don't have the
equivalent of a a resistance group they
are literally under the mercy of this uh
of this uh of this one strongest armies
in the world you know they don't have
Google in China gole not allow yeah most
social media is not allowed in China
yeah that's another Point as well yeah
no WhatsApp no YouTube W they got they
got their own D so I was trying to make
this as a complimentary point cuz aan
was making the point that look it's
there's an economic disincentive because
Islam abolishes a lot of stuff that they
they bread and but
but it's also a
civilizational disincentive and that is
they realize that if Islam puts itself
together civilization it becomes the
immediate competitor and it has the
ability to overtake and it has overtaken
before all you have to do is look at the
history it's overtaken so many times
before they know what we're capable of
so they have to suppress us without so
appealing to conspiracy yeah you know
everything you said about um you know F
and 200 years ago there was a guy by the
name of Albert Pike okay Albert Pike
he's a um first 33 degree Freemason yeah
in one of his books it does mention that
the final battle will be between the
West really in Islam what's his
name he mentions this 200 years American
General yeah so it's a spiritual thing
as well apparently they say he claimed
himself that he could summon Lucifer
anytime he wanted that's what he would
claim himself wow well yeah amazing and
apparently Lucifer um spoke to him in a
dream and he orchestrated three world
wars through this dream and the World
War I on World War I already was was he
Albert Pike he's a I think an American
General really yeah a 33 degree uh uh
freemer my God yeah I'm but and we have
to be honest uh I'm not going into too
much detail cuz last time I see someone
speak about this their video was
actually taken down well we're Rumble we
got free speech over here we'll be okay
yeah well let me say anyway which
is I'll be honest and I'm I'm not going
to there this
Hadith okay I'm about the end of
times and these Hadith basically say and
they're very specific Hadith bro and
I've never I can't tell you what they
mean exactly but they say the end of
times the Muslims are going to make an
alliance with Al Al could either be one
of two people there are two put it in
Huntington C civilizations which are
connected to a rule now which is the
west and the EAS Orthodox like the
Russians and it says that they going to
make a they go to make an alliance in
the end of days and there's going to be
a great war that takes place and this
great war is going to have an army which
is composed of 12 flags and each flag
has
80,000 uh people inside of it now if you
add that up it's 960,000 people that's a
million people bro in the medieval
period you don't find armies that big
this was not a medieval Army this is a
Wen day Army the biggest army in the
world today an active Reserve Act active
force is the Chinese Army and there's a
million people in that bro you know so
it's that's a million people it's a
Chinese Army we're talking about an army
this Hadith is referring to something
very modern where there will be an army
of a million people bro an army of a
million
the entire what would be the equivalent
of the entire active Personnel of the
biggest army in the world now America
doesn't have that many it has like what
400 400,000 500,000 something like that
active personel not reservist active
personel so the point I'm making to is
it then says that these people that this
a rule they will go against the alliance
and basically it's going to Signal the
end of days BL this is when the is
coming and the and uh all that stuff can
happen
but it seems to me everything is clearly
moving in that direction when is the end
when when is the jaw going to show up do
you do you think it's coming real soon I
loveam but here's the thing brother
mentioned it before
yesterday there's you know the minor
signs and the major signs of the day of
judgment yeah the minor signs are almost
all done yeah which is mad because
there's like there's so there's so many
of them there's like 50 or 60 of them so
one of them was like let give you an
example or something one of them was the
conquest of jerus Jem Islam conquered
Jerusalem in the first 10 years of Islam
with yeah that was done quickly so
another one is like for example the
competing of the T buildings we talked
about that yesterday another one is
interest the spread of Interest well can
you imagine this there's a Hadith that
says that interest will be so
widespread whoever doesn't consume the
interest he will be afflicted by it
stuff that's Hadith bro one of the
things that the prophet said is that
there'll be sexually transmitted
diseases but by the way not just stvs St
STDs that will come about there'll be
Advent of
STDs due to sexual prcu Mony bars no
that is there there's one million people
in L yeah one million people BR did you
get
monkey you know you know you know he
didn't answer though
what's funny I remember when this was
going around here I I I was vomited I
was sick here and there was these spots
around my back
here so I saw the ambulance they came
they took me yeah and
then I was I was in the I was in the
ambulance and then I can hear the Nur is
going we can't take him
in we can't take him in we need to we
need to see if there the monkey BG there
no way and I was like monkey po the
about bro then I I that me did they ask
you if you were homosexual sorry no that
no they were just like oh is
it bro I came across a Hadith talking
about homosexuality but it says they
been new disease that's never heard of
before yeah no that's that's that's
authentic there's a there's a weak
Hadith very interesting yeah you know it
goes it's say a we Hadith I'm me
clear
go that a man will be satisfied with
only a man he doesn't need a woman in
life so be gay
gay okay and a woman will be satisfied
well she's lesbian but even do you know
like heard yeah's moving wet there is
even do you know the feminist movement
that the woman will get into the
workforce there's a Hadith talk about
that that the woman will now go into the
workforce so now we're going to see the
major size of the anti com in yeah so
effectively the like I would say 95% of
the minor so you know you know what's
interesting about the what the prophet
said I don't know if it's authentic once
the Min son done by the way IM com say
it's a minor sign some it's a major sign
so now what they say is that the major
signs will happen like you know like a
beat when you cut a bead yeah and it
will fall one after another the major
the major signs would happen one after
another so it wouldn't be like a time
time so it just shows you that we are
literally like on the V of through can I
ask I'm I'm learning more about this and
I was speaking to a Jewish fan of mine
he came up to me and he was like oh why
do you speak that why I I don't I'm not
anti-semitic at all but I I'll speak
about all religions and so I was
learning more I bottom on stream again
and and I was I was telling him about
how Jesus the Messiah Islam because he's
saying that we don't believe in Jesus
but it's actually a misconception that
that Christians don't realize that we we
believe that Jesus is the Messiah and I
was asking him what he believes and he
was describing the the Jewish Messiah
and I'd never heard about this term
before well I don't remember what the
word is mashik mik or something like
that basically in Islam the jaw is the
mashik their own Messiah is the jaw and
exactly let me let me ask you a question
I speak some Christians yeah they come
and say Islam is the D's religion Etc I
say very simple thead is going to be a
being human being who is going to claim
what that he is and he's going to do
what Miracles who believes that God is a
man and does Miracles the Christians the
trinitarian
Christians so who's going to for for the
Trap of you know and and of course we
have gracians that they'll
be the point is this so luy brother
so so the point is this Aki if you think
about it you guys are the ones that
believe God can become a man and we do
Miracles so that and I'm doesn't wake
you up hello and it just doesn't you see
they I'm like if there's anyone that's
going for the D it's you because he's
going to come and say I'm God I'm Divine
what he can't make himself look like
Jesus and put some marks on his hand so
the point is here it's
very is it really difficult he's going
to control the weather there's so many
things even in the Bible that says so
again they are the ones that's going to
follow that message defense of the
Christians cuz there's a lot of them
watching I did see a video I I want to
bring it up in defense of them of uh I
think it was nearby in in England
somewhere there were this whole Majid
and there was a guy going oh
chuu reacted chu chu yeah Tru gu and
then they're all doing this chu chu
thing and thinking that it's going to go
give them well I don't know what it was
Innovation but the whole Maj was was
believing in Tru Tru and these are the
people that are going to these are the
people that will believe in the jaw when
the jaw comes I thought that was
Pakistan bro it was Birmingham Am I
Wrong Birmingham bro bro when I heard
that I Pakistan it was birming they were
holding the hand like this it was a
birmingh was happening so F but the
the's going to be the majority of
followers of like well the ones the ch
ch people are going to fall for it women
not wom women are going women too of
course not it was Bradford
right I mean women are naturally
inherently followers yes mentality Etc
it's they they are m b what does the had
say you have have to chain them up y
we're not asking to chain you anybody up
here lik
[Laughter]
that go like
wildan do you see signs of the end times
or is this is this paranoid thinking is
it even worth speaking about because
it's all prophesize and it's out of our
control one one thing that I've noticed
and this was happening even in India as
well that there was there's Prophet hint
the B of him and what what happens with
these prophecies is sometimes we rely
too much on these prophecies and we say
oh it's going to be this this particular
thing the end times are coming I even
when I post videos and it becomes more
and more crazier with regards to what
sort of stuff is going on it's all yeah
current affairs just current affairs
stuff that's going on I see people going
the day of jine is close now the J is
going to be here very soon M but we
don't know how long it's going to take
might take one year might take 5 years
10 years 50 years 100 years 200 years
you just don't know and this whole thing
that yes the the you know signs of the
day of judgment are going to happen
they're going to happen when they're
going to happen but for us as people
living to just rely on them and go you
know what forget I I can't do anything I
just lock everything off well like he
says it tongling cheeks I'm ready for
the asteroid now yeah you know obviously
it doesn't mean it like that but the
thing is that when when some people rely
on it too much and it leads to inaction
and they think you know what it's going
to happen soon we don't know when it's
going to happen yes it's enough of a
sign for us to realize that you know
what years and times and yes these are
not good things to be happening these
are not things to be
celebrated however we continue doing
whatever is in our power for example we
go Speakers Corner we continue going
Speakers Corner even if the day of
judgment comes as a narration to suggest
that even if you're prating something
finish prating it yeah because that's
that's your job that's where you you're
supposed to do don't stop doing
something just because oh they just I
just leave this here because you're
still supposed to finish what you're
doing and you still you know not not
only that when it comes to the why we
so this that there's a Hadi of the of
the pro piece of a young boy and I feel
in show paraphrasing he says
that like before he dies will see some
see be a judgment something those BS but
the point was what the moment you dies
you be a judgment M the moment you die
that's the Hereafter that's all that
unseen thing you want to wait for the
Jud get you're going to see more more of
that work on the day of judgment that's
going to start for you when you die and
that can be any second not forget 10
years when is the J com 50 years old you
predict it forget that the moment you
die J exactly the moment you die is your
day of judgment cuz you're going to see
the Unseen you're going to be see those
angels that we were talking about you're
going to be asked the questions so your
day of judgment is dead worry about that
because people are very speculating War
forget that your day of judgment will
start but then you die so work on that
day and it just amazes me many people
are working on like being graduating
from University when our celebrated
they're so fixated people call me please
make Dua that I pass my exams like it's
good like I appreciate effort but do you
put the same effort to the exam that is
it's your destiny man it is just going
to be the thing that when your the angel
of death comes and takes your soul and
if I was I was deep in this couple years
ago I spoke to you as well is that just
think about it the most important thing
in my life is this the moment I die and
I'm I'm not saying that the angels have
a mouth or nothing but just I just want
to know I just want to hear The
Following come out to the mercy I'm done
bro that's that's that's that's the
thing I've been waiting for All My Life
coming out to the mercy of Allah because
if they say come out to the wrath of
your lord these are the two options
these are the two options by the way so
when our soul is taken the angels will
either come and say come out to the
mercy of your lord or come out to the
wrath of your lord yeah the most
important thing for any believer is when
I die that inshah it will be that the
angel say come out to the mercy of your
lord the moment they say Mercy bro it's
like bro alhamdulillah past P that's
what I care about I don't care about
this or that but nor many people fixated
it's like it's like a game for of
Netflix when's the com when is theide
because even if the these things are
happening like how does it affect your
daily life it doesn't it does you know
what I mean and also the but it does
show you the reality of these things as
well and you know obviously you made a
fantastic point but also one of the ways
we could possibly predict what is
happening is pay attention to the people
waiting for him if these people these
soal people waiting for him and they're
going to do the rituals in order to you
know give the jal's powers then why
don't we just keep an eye on them and
and and instead of waiting for M why
don't you prepare to be like him yeah
waiting for the brother why don't you
try to be like him why you waiting for a
savior why don't you start working if
the um if everybody did their part bro
well why people talk about oh we need to
advise that sister doesn't hijab
correctly or that brother smoke him if
everybody Focus on their family and fix
their family nobody needs to one that
that's such a good point because even
our duas as well when we supplicate now
is Ramadan before we open our fast the
Dua that we make there's a strong
possibility of it being accepted and one
of the duas should be oh Allah think
about your lineage oh Allah make my
children such that they will be on the
side of the M that they will be on the
side of isaam rather than the side of
the Jal rather than disgracing the
religion they will be honoring the
religion and that's the thing there was
a she who's who who's somewhat famous
now and they said you know what made you
come on the right path he said when I
would get up in the morning and I would
come down the stairs I I could hear my
father weeping on the prayer mat oh
Allah guide my son and he said that when
I would see somebody as masculine as him
and he has his stuff together but he's
on the prayer map and he's crying and
who is he crying for he's crying for me
he said that made me you know that
really kind of got to me so it's stuff
like this that hearing stuff like that
like the brother rightly said it should
get us to to kind of it should motivate
us into action that you know what this
is what I see in some of my videos
towards the end that after mentioning
the current affair I say if this isn't
going to wake you up if this isn't going
to show you that now is the time to
change now is the time to turn closer to
Allah then when is you know what I mean
if you all these signs taking place what
are you waiting for you know I mean like
now is the time well before I go to the
next question I have to change the
camera B if you give me uh 10 seconds
further where do you stream this R what
was that thing about I heard did mention
name in
the not the parliament the Amer you were
mentioning the parliament something
about oh I they mention your name about
what they said it was uh promoting
hatred in the United States for I can't
believe your name was mentioned yeah was
that antisemitism the stre anti-Semitism
yeah now'll get that's the number one
really that's the number one are we back
yeah I want so we went to Speakers
Corner today you you were all there I
want to ask all of you like what do you
get specifically out of that because I I
was talking to to my friends and we were
trying to figure it out it was uh pretty
entertaining it's it's a fun playground
for adults it's it's good to go back and
forth um of course like the people that
watch the stream they love to debate
about stuff like this all day ultimately
uh a lot of it is is is kind of a waste
of time for for most people but it's a
good mental exercise uh I want but
before we get there can I can I share a
couple of things with you Aki okay cuz I
was just um on the I I find it
interesting we close the door the Min
yes um there's some Hadith I came across
recently very interesting about the SI
of their judment because I I think this
actually constitutes one of the best
Arguments for go for the truth of Islam
because this you don't need to have
linguistic ability or we already spoke
about some of the stuff before like for
instance the in River or the idea that
interest will increase and Zilla you
know for example will lead tods or like
the idea of prist STDs the to buildings
where Islam was spread what countries
and so on but let me give you some other
Hadith very interesting yeah this is
narrated by is he said a woman will be
taken and her stomach will be ripped
open then what is in her womb will be
taken out and discarded for of given
birth this is a Hadith
authentic can you imagine can you see
how deep that is yeah I mean this is
these are the kinds of things that is
predicted before the day of judgment so
let me say again yeah again one more
time yeah that AB
uh narrated and this is
in it's authentic authentic Hadith says
a woman will be taken yes and her
stomach will be ripped open then what is
and her wo will be taken out and
discarded for fear of given birth this
is clear what it's talking abouto right
it's talking about abortion abortion
which is but can you imagine moreon than
that is so precise specific to that is
unbelievably precise they're having a
you know they celebrate abortions in the
street of New York they have um y yell
for abortion where women will go in the
street and they'll celebrate it like
another thing that came to mind I don't
know if it R about isn't that a
C-section because a woman is afraid of
give birth could and it's a C-section
could be so so listen to this
here another thing which is mentioned
which is really powerful is
um there's a Hadith it goes goes follows
yeah the hour will not be established
until you fight a took yeah who are
these me
Turkish it's not it's not Turkish is
because turkey is a Modern Nation it's
not it's not about turkey Turkish people
it's talking about Turk people and
there's a difference so like the Mongols
and some on their TOS so listen to what
he says yeah people with small eyes red
faces and flat nose Asians yeah but it's
not just any Asians it's very specific
Asians okay who is it their faces will
look like Shields coed with leather
their hourl will not be established till
you fight with people whose shoes are
made of hair now these
people and I'll give you another Hadith
this is bukari by the way this Hadith
coming up here is Abu because some of my
people will align on low Ling ground
which they call Al Basra beside a river
called uh digla the tigis over there is
a bridge its people will be numerous and
it will be one of the capital cities of
immigrants at the End of Time the
descendants of Kara will come with broad
faces small eyes that are line on the
bank of the river the town's inhabitants
will then separate into three sections
one of which will follow cattle and live
in the desert and perish another which
will seek security for themselves and
perish but a third will put their
children behind their backs and fight
the Invaders and they will be the
martyrs so who is is talking about it's
very clearly talking about
Mongols is now this if you look at what
happened with the Mongols it's one of
the most significant historical moments
ever you just research the Mongols and
how the Mongols interacted with the
Muslims there was a massive fight that
took between the Mongols and the and the
Muslims it led to actually the Mongols
convert to Islam there's a whole history
behind that but the Precision of that
Hadith because those Mongols bro they
had shoes that were made out of
hair the the same thing that is
mentioned the Hadith exactly happened
now you imagine Constantinople is
mentioned Hadith which is the Crown
Jewel of the Roman Empire that that will
be overtaken it's isul today isul today
you had Jerusalem mentioned the Hadith
that will be overtaken you have the
Mongols you have the most significant
events in history between the time of
the prophet and now spelled out in the
most precise way so you know what like
for example there's a prediction that is
made of quan Sunnah it's there to show
us that if God can get all of these so
right so what it comes to at
when it comes to um Al when it comes to
the second coming of Jesus Christ if is
already proof that these prophecies came
correct like that then surely we should
accept Okay it's only a matter of time
now but that's why this is the this is
the benefit of the minor signs of the
day of judgment bro what are the minor
signs is that obes obesity will become
widespread obesity role is mentioned a
Hadith it's the fattest America's ever
been and and two yeah the UK and bro
it's unbelievable how much how
much uh sophistication and precision
there is uh some general Trends I
mentioned for example um that knowledge
will become very widespread extremely
widespread literacy written material be
overly widespread but also that money
will be completely widespread not only
that but with knowledge wise there will
be ignorance ignorance will be very
profound everyone with yes cuz we about
wise more knowled that's a very good
point so you have these two almost you
would not think that these two Trends
will come together but in one aspect
from another perspective actually the
despite the increase of knowledge there
it's still ignorant so it's like having
tons of books but no one's reading them
yes why cuz Google you can just Google
it there's no memorization yet yet
that's a good one will be naked
clo so look at this look at this Muslim
yeah so and you know the B Sister
sometimes they wear clothes
tight you know you can see everything
because there are some that are absolute
see-through but they've got CLA but you
can see everything bro do you know that
Hadith is so interesting cuz it's Muslim
the way it goes is this is it goes that
there will be a time
yeah where people will be traveling in
these things called yeah I explain what
this means is authentic it's auth Muslim
Muslim yeah it's the second most
authentic book in Islam after the Quran
the Muslim and it says that this they'll
be traveling and they'll be
reclining inside the Sur is a name for a
ship okay now classically you had these
Roman ships which actually had little
wheels on them so it's saying that you
have some ship likee things that are
going to be moving around on the on the
ground on the Earth and people are going
to be reclining inside of them listen to
this yeah they're going to be reclining
inside of them and inside of this
vehicle there's going to be woman in
women that what are they dressed like
Adat
catat casad means they're
dressed but they're act they're clothed
but they appear unclothed now
effectively all the have said this means
what two things it means that their
clothes are so tight that they might as
well be naked that's Miami that's every
girl in Miami you see walk around the
gender are so tight you see their whole
body yeah or it could mean that they're
wearing such little clothes that this
doesn't classify as covering it doesn't
really yeah it doesn't te it doesn't
classify you're not covering yourself
that's not the way that traditionally
how you would how someone would cover
themselves so can you imagine bro these
are the things that the kinds of
examples of what the Prophet Muhammad
sallam he said would happen before the
day of before before all of these things
which we're talking about because it may
seem theoretical but if we're talking
about 90% And I've just given you like
only 10 examples yeah 10 or 15 examples
90% of of this kind of stuff 90 to 95%
has has come true it seems incredulous
oh this other stuff is not going to
happen but it will happen quickly bro
and I think it's going to happen is
might happen in our lifetimes the day of
judgment might happen in all of our
lifetimes it's a possibility we don't
know what it's going to be what what are
some signs of the end times in the
Israel Palestine conflict right now I I
was speaking to the Warner in sometimes
like I I've heard talks of how Israel
might be guarding some some some books
and some information that there there's
something deeper that's happening in in
this war that that has to do so the
thing is yeah I actually looked into
this cuz I was interested cuz I I came
across these
hadiths about Gaza in particular
Gaza the Hadith about Hadith about Gaza
about Gaza however all of the about Gaza
about the tree what about the but that's
different let me get to the Gaza one I
can read it for you if you like okay
because actually yes this and I was
uh one
second as he's getting that there's
something that's just come out a couple
of days ago thank you for reading that I
didn't know what you're looking at I
thought he was texting you to the board
yeah he's finding it but there's
something called the um the red heer oh
yeah so that's
something so this is this is a prophecy
of the the Jews so they believe that
they need to find so again I'm
paraphrasing you can jump in which is
they need to find a red heer that toin
certain criteria it needs to be clean
unblemished needs to be read it needs to
be like this like that for years decades
centuries possibly even they've been
searching for it and they haven't found
it however only recently they found five
in T yeah and using American Airlines
they've transported them over and they
believe that this red heer a um once
it's sacrificed and it's burnt and there
are certain pure priests then uh when
you know that whole situation is cleared
then you know
AA um the Temple mount the Temple Mount
M yeah Mas
ala you know Masa so that's the third
holiest place in Islam where is that
okay that wasn't bombed was it no so
that's a mosque isn't it that's that's
like a courtyard Courtyard like yes so
that whole Courtyard is is called um AA
okay so that of course Muslims go
there and you know alhamdulillah
fantastic but for years they've been you
know weakening some people say that yeah
they've been weakening the foundations
this used to be like a Fring of opion
that they want to build the Third Temple
the Temple of Solomon on there they so
it was it was a very Fring opinion but
now it's so mainstream even in politics
that this is something that is is
ridiculous To Deni and they say why do
they need to be the build the F Temple
for the coming of who for the for the
coming of they they say the
Messiah yeah so the and the evangelicals
are trying to continue this as well or
rather to catalyze this because they
believe that of course Messiah is going
to come so they are aligning in this do
the Jews admit that they're waiting for
the coming of the Antichrist no no no of
course no of they don't an you say yes
you say no no no no Antichrist they is
the Messiah but we say is the like you
said remember cuz they don't accept
Jesus as so how but how why don't they
accept that as Antichrist if it's no no
no they they going to think it's the
Messiah but it's going to be the
Antichrist the Jews are going to follow
them the Christians are going to follow
him and not only that they who is it
they said 40 um foran or somewhere they
going to have a following but it's
really Antichrist in reality but just to
finish this point the as follow him
right because because they found the red
now the prophecy they're going to once
they found it in April they're saying
that that's when they're going to Ena
this ceremony so the next coming year or
so is going to be very indicative
because according to their prophecy they
should start building the Third Temple
from and once they start doing that
I mean there's going to be well
hopefully there's going to be uproar but
the way things are now with what's going
on in Palestine there's supposed to be
upro but which country do we see
speaking out so when AKA gets taken
who's going to speak out what thees that
that that r on the Americans with the
jordanians that that rely on the
Americans the Saudi the only country
that's named after their King that of
course was done at the the Advent of the
demolishing of the otoman Empire I mean
what what can we really hope for but
people are saying that from April so
this is cuz you asked for their prophecy
this is their prophecy and you can setar
this up as well it's called the red heer
prophecy it's making the rounds as well
but this is really look something across
the Hadith bro and this go that will
happen in the next month this year in
April they're saying that that's when
they're going to enact this out and then
push push forward that building there
has to be caveat mate because the idea
of accelaration accelerating the process
of the coming of Mahi or the Antichrist
is something that is propagated by the
zist the religious Jews believe that you
cannot accelerate the process it is
something that happens natur ex this
only design is to interested and they
would only come if there's no state of
Israel yes cuz they believed that for
for for them their me their Messiah to
come there should be no is there should
be no Israel of Israel yeah so when they
try to build a third Temple so what's
happen in this bro they try to build a
fa Temple to for their Messiah to come
and the Christians the the the Jewish
the lobby the Theus Lobby in America are
Christians by the way the reason they're
promoting this is because saying when
this happens Jesus Jesus will come so
when Jesus will come he'll kill the the
Jews and everybody for that matter so
the Christians are supporting the Jews
even though they don't understand the
enemy of my enemy is my friend so what
they're doing is is like let's promote
this because when this happens Jesus
will come which is going to be I thought
they were just brainwashed no they are
very calculated this a religious thing
they know so there there Jesus is D and
then the the the Messiah of the Jews is
d right you know there there's a Hadith
I just come across now before before you
read theith quickly I just want to say I
was going to ask like what could we do
in preparation for this but if it's all
prophesized there's nothing we really
can do this is all going to happen it's
supposed to happen so the the people
watching right now if they're getting
scared and like what do I do is there
anything we can yeah says in the Quran
save yourself and your fire your family
from fire yourself and your family so
sometimes people want to save the whole
world be self-sufficient first look
listen save yourself and your family
please first before you want to go and
save the whole world it's very important
it's a reminder for myself first some I
go give that everybody but my house my
brother my mom you we need to simp focus
is everybody walk focused on their
family our goal is what to die on that
Allah doesn't want the results he just
wants you to die on the path not the end
I don't want to see the end I just want
to die on the path that should be our
main focus because what's going to
happen is going to happen do you get it
and and there is prophecies what for
that Muslims are be going to conquer
jerus Jesus is going to come he's going
to kill the there's going to be peace on
Earth Jesus is going to get married so
there's going to be peace he going to
he's going to kill the D so doing these
things are going to happen so this
period will definitely end but the thing
is there's life is all about Peaks and
troughs that's why even when you see a
person in hospital and then you look at
the beep beep beep it's up down and
that's indicative of what life is it
goes up then it comes down I mean the
end end time correct me if I'm wrong
will be somebody that will go up to the
ca this will be right towards the end
and will take it apart brick from brick
yeah so at the time of Jesus that will
be our peak time yeah and there's always
Peaks and troughs that's just the way
the world works and to answer what he's
asking what are we supposed to do the
very fact that we know about this
science cuz the sahabas they would make
this like a life mission to know all the
science the reason why they wanted to
know all the science is in preparation
to know to um differentiate between the
Antichrist and Jesus Christ by knowing
the signs the signs are an indication
okay I have to prepare myself the
prophet M talks about theide that there
will be people that will remove
themselves from society and they will go
away to the mountains and worship God to
stay away from the influences of J so
knowing the signs is the preparation
itself against um so some people like
you mentioned they'll be praying they'll
be praying for the lineage that Allah
protects their lineage like d says as
well
bro some people are making Hijra they're
moving to Muslim countries as you've
heard in your circles as well some
people are moving to Dubai some people
are moving to Turkey some people are
saying you know what it's we actually
can't live in certain countries some
people they know that for example when
the whole AA thing happens I mean you do
whatever you can is you know is is
around you and that's that's all you can
do like Ali mentioned as well so you
marry all of these things together and
you do whatever is your means like if
your buildings on fire you're never
going to be able to rescue everybody and
you're never going to be able to change
everything but you can change what's
around you and you want to be that flame
to the darkness that's around you and if
there's enough Flames that's enough to
light up the room but you can't light up
the entire room that's not in your hands
yeah there will always be people that
choose the darkness and you can't change
that and that's why even the prophet's
uncle there were examples even in the
prophet's life it's Uncle didn't accept
Islam so guidance ultimately some people
just look at the prophet they accept
Islam so that's what it comes down to
understanding and acknowledging
everything lies in our hands or in the
control of Allah but we do there's a
saying do your best Allah will do the
rest that's what we can do do your best
Allah will do the
rest Amen
brother got it's very interesting
because I I I have already thought that
all of these Hadith are weak about Gaza
and ashalon you know you might have seen
what happened on the news ashalon became
quite popular because Ashan is right
next to Gaza asalan it's called as you
might heard in the now there are two
Asal there's one in Egypt and one in but
near but the one that is mentioned in
theith is actually the one near okay now
if you this is what the Hadith says and
this Hadith has been authenticated by
the likes of yeah it's not a weak Hadith
it says the first of this matter is a
prophecy and mercy then it becomes a
caliphate and mercy so we've already had
that we had prophecy we have Cal then it
becomes kingship and mercy that's
exactly what happened because you have
the then you have the always yeah then
it becomes the dictatorship and mercy
that's what we have now so this is how
theam is telling us exactly what has
happened in history is what's happened
in terms of governance of godheads right
this this then they will fight over it
like the the fighting of hungry camels
they will they're going to be fighting
over different things over the fighting
of like hungry
camels so point you is to engage in Jad
thisi says and indeed the best of your
Jihad is
patience and the best of your patience
is at the beginning okay so Jihad to be
attacked and you and and you and the
best of your Jihad is
inan what
isanan is do you know the S say
uh what we saw ashalon it's in the kabot
right outside of Gaza so you've got Gaza
here ashon is like is a 10minute drive
from
G so what is if you imagine the lines
here that have been
drawn uh this Hadith indicates it could
indicate that the Muslim governance the
moment that the Jihad reaches
there that's something's going to happen
that's going to reach to the end of this
and that's why I think the Palestine
issue it could be the trigger for World
War I and
then if you think about it just think
about this because here is saying Hadith
is clear but it's unbelievable how clear
this Hadith is how can the prophet wasam
if you know the history of like Islamic
history this is Undisputed history first
you had the prophet then you
had then you had exactly what the
prophet said then you had the Abid and
the the and the ab break it down they
were Kings it's like Mony then after
that what do we have now in the Muslim
world we have dictators it's
authoritarian regime it's not a
democracy it is a dictatorship in most
of the countries there's 59 Muslim
majority countries most of them are
characterized by authoritarian regime
this is exactly according to the Hadith
this is the second the penultimate stage
of
History so right now it's like if we're
reading a book this is the second to
last chapter we are on the second to
last chapter the next chapter is the
conclusion of the book of History the
end of history
for the real end of History honestly so
what I'm saying is that and that Hadith
was so why does it indicate as
bro let me let me let's be clear about
something with the current Gaza
conflict the current Gaza conflict
showed us it's unlikely that the small
band of resistance Fighters whoever they
may be in Gaza are going to overtake
newand let's be honest let's say for
example now militarily and strategically
if
Hamas what is the best they can hope for
a resistance that they can like repel
the enemy outside of Gaza that's the
best they can ask they can hope no one
is predicting that Hamas or any other
resistance group in Gaza will go into
ashalon which is or any of the which is
by the way Run next to T Aviv ashalon is
on the way to T Aviv bro really yeah Ash
so you've got here what separ is it it's
kabot only a few towns bro between by
the way between Gaza and Tel Aviv is an
hour in driving in terms between Gaza
and ashalon is 10 minutes 15 minutes you
can you can go to it by running jogging
it's not far that's not that far away so
what I'm saying is bro is unlikely that
a place like ashalon will be overtaken
by anything other than a combined effort
of the Muslim
armies and the moment that happens
everyone knows the moment that happens
is it may be a trip it might be like you
know how France ferand World War I that
was a catalyst World War apparently yeah
they say it right but it can be the
alliance system that can have a a system
like that bro it could be that this
thing about Palestine is going to lead
to the end of day could be which shows
you this is a special place and this is
connected to these very many authentic
Hadith
authentic Muslim all of these that there
will be a to mans there will be a saved
sect now there's an idea of Saved sect
there's some people in Britain that they
think they're the sav sect to be H these
wab no they called
the they say we are the safe sect you
know problem
yeah so they say they say that they say
they the the safe sect where they
Proclaim but listen if you read the
Hadith from the safe sect you know what
the things says about that they will be
around they'll be around around aam
they'll be they'll be in that area so
why are you doing in Britain no no this
is so it says the save sect is going to
be around Jerusalem not shepher Bush not
shepher Bush not Birmingham it doesn't
say Birmingham there
what doesn't say it says going to be so
so can you imagine here this shows you
number one the virtue of the Palestinian
people and of the people in that area
because there's a reason why Allah is
taking these people as am Matas well why
there's the reason for that the reason
is because look how humble they are
they're the opposite of s say Zionist
everything is the Zionist these guys are
the opposite they're showing humility
they're showing this and that and
Reliance the zist are arrogant they want
to kill the babies it's like pharaoh and
Moses well the zist are like Pharaoh in
the in the Bible bro in the Quran they
like they remind me of pharaoh modern
day Pharaoh so what I'm saying is no it
seems to me it seems to me that this
is a key part of the story bro and you
know that it's a controversial Hadith
but we mention it very controversial in
the end of days there will be a fight
between Muslims and the Jews and the
Hadith says that the Jew there will be a
tree
called tree and it will say this the
tree will somehow speak or
communicate with the Muslim and say
there's a Jew behind me come and kill
him there's a Drew behind me come and
kill him okay now why is it
controversial because they say oh
because it's
anti-semitic okay you
know it's not talking about Jewish
babies and children yeah and the
Innocents and it just so happens sorry
to say majority of zionists are Jewish
our beefers with the Zionist and most of
the Zionist in the world if you did the
poll on them they you don't find like uh
black nationalist Zionist you don't find
you know Hindus I mean you do find some
of those so to say witho whatever but
that's something else
what I'm saying
is 25,000 Jews will be following the J
and I'll have to look at the I got a
question let me get this one but this so
this one here what I'm saying is the
that the eschatological picture of Islam
is that in the end of times there will
be a clash of civilization and part of
it clearly Muslims will be against some
Jewish people some zist people let say
Sig bro this is too delicate it's
mentioning the names of the city it's
mentioning the key areas of BR ashar was
on the news the other day
bro bro ashar was that's where Hamas got
killed that's where they were fighting
the people that's when they went out and
that was Asar oh wow bro they came out
and they they got shot dead in ashar
they went out to ashon with the you know
with the paraglider they went to ashalon
Bro where where did they think they went
this is too delicate it shows you that
the the Prophecies of the Hadith are too
in line now with the geopolitical
relevancies of the day bro we need to
really this for me when I think about
all this Hadith I think the the day of
judgment is coming BR it's coming it's
it's close how soon do you think I don't
know you do a lot more research on this
than I thought you did like I I thought
you would be the type of person to be
like there's no point in researching
this there's no point in like no no I I
like this but we I don't I don't try and
speculate there's a lot of Hadith that
you can put a lot of speculation into it
but this bro like you know this is
pretty clear bro this is clear cut bro
in it well you don't think it's worth it
just protect your family there's no
point in in trying to change what's
already I'm just seeing that for example
these things are important it's good to
educate the fact the J does but to now
get this whole and we're we're finished
or what can I do what I'm seeing is that
yeah that's what I'm saying on the card
that's going to happen this what's in
Palestine we're finished no this
shouldn't be the of the believer so what
I'm seeing is that if everybody
internally corrected their Affair then
this will have a ripple effect the
reason why in the state we are is
because of our love for the world what
I'm saying is we need to reverse that
and put our love to living for and dying
for if every Muslim done that w we will
not be in this situation because we are
far away from that so it all starts here
because everybody has big plans like
let's open this let's do this let's
conquer first start with yourself
imagine living that lifestyle partying
holidays girls bro I would either be
suicidal or me a mental institute bro I
cannot cannot live your life the same
boring pattern bro what is your purpose
what is your purpose boring just think
about it bro what is your purpose
everything has a purpose this lid has a
purpose and your purpose is what to go
sleep around uh Drive night is are you
kidding me what a disservice to the body
that God gave you so to me it's just
like in a nut just choose who you're
going to be who you're going to worship
it's either Allah or it's it's either
going to be multiple other things from
the and you will never be happy for you
you know I think it is as well for that
this is my reading of the guys fresh
it's not just them but it's the whole
like Manos thing right pill do you know
what the issue is the issue is like most
Societies in history have had what you
call rights of Passage for men okay
there's something that a man does at one
point of his life which shows the
community shows himself shows his family
that this guy's a man now whether it's
go to war enroll in the military do
something like that bar mitzvah for
example yeah but like usually it's
something to show the resolve of the man
the masculine nature of the man right
something physical something hard to do
something hard hunting this and that
something pretty SE we don't really have
that anymore exactly so because we
haven't had that now people have come
out and they've got different things
which they've invented as right s
passage now I feel like a lot of the
mistake that the manosphere makes I'm
not going to say fresh and fit because
it's the whole manosphere the whole
ideology yeah yeah which is like okay
now the rights of Passage is how many
women can you sleep with okay that's
basically it the more that you can sleep
with the more of a man you are okay but
if if that's what is your rights of
Passage then you'll never you'll never
compete with a donkey or a bunny rabbit
the donkey and the bunny rabbit will
always uh out over overdo you or outdo
you in this regard because it doesn't
take skill it doesn't take resolve it
doesn't take power it doesn't take
strength for someone to copulate of
course to bend a woman over and to you
know do this and that put her in
different positions and I know I'm going
through details
here no you know what I mean it's not
it's not it doesn't take any level of
proficiency or efficiency or skill or
anything like that really this is a what
you would call a false rights of Passage
which is I think there's been there's
been some kind of a gulf that has there
is a CM because of modern society
the lack of hardship that's been created
and they're filling up with heathenism
what I'm saying is that objectively it
doesn't make you cuz what is it to be a
man that's the most question I have to
start with
it what is it to be a man for me the the
defining attribute of a man
frankly is
bravery that is the for me the defining
attribute of what it means to be a real
man is bravery because you need that in
abundance to do certain things for
example provide
protect now you're not going to prove
your bravery which is the if you're like
the main virtue that you require to be a
man because frankly if what would you
say to someone if if if they were not
brave You' say they were a coward if
they're not coward You' say you're not a
man someone gets slapped in the face and
then he couldn't couldn't fight back or
someone slaps your wife in the face and
you can't fight her you can't defend her
you're not a manad anymore you know
that's what we were saying vernacularly
and in virtue ethics all the way from
Aristotle up until our times it was
always known that bravery was the
Cardinal and redeeming virtue of a man
that differentiated him from woman not
to say that woman don't have that virtue
now going back to the the the rights of
Passage issue the rights of Passage
issue now having sex with women how does
that prove that you're a brave man it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't prove that
you're a brave man that you're a
resilient man that you're a skillful man
or anything like that so for
me uh this idea of increasing the body
count and stuff like that and I I find
it to be a lousy It's a lazy idea it's a
weak idea it does prove Ry it's at the
lowest possible level what even I mean
what is it showing you so say
your instrument to another woman it's
like what a bunny rabbit can do or or
donkey and having inter with the doesn't
show anything it doesn't show anything
at all frankly it doesn't show anything
so deep you saying this cuz my dad he
would tap me on the shoulder and say in
French Kash yeah courage courage courage
say you're a man there going to be a lot
of things that you're going to face he
knew already fora this yeah stuff that
I'm going from now I providing for
family I haven't making decision for the
family facing reality and being I do not
know where my money is going to come
from I don't know where this is going to
come from yeah but I have to be
courageous that is the main thing bro
and there's two kinds of Courage so
there is you can say you call it the
physical courage and you call it the
moral courage moral courage so the
physical courage is getting in in in
getting engaged in physical
confrontation so for example I I'll
reference something you done and I
mention this to you but the thing was
Strickland I think I think that was a
show of Courage actually because the guy
the guy the guy was actually people
don't realize this the guy is one of the
most dangerous human beings on this
planet so he didn't step in the ring
with him that requires courage and to
know that he's going to potentially hurt
you bro badly and he tried to hurt him
he tried to kill him bro and he couldn't
Allah protected alhamdulillah but that
is a kind of Courage I think if you look
at the comments of that particular Al
people saying my respectful sneo has
gone up so much and this and that why
because men realize okay that that
wasn't easy for him okay but he still
didn't capitulate he didn't give up he
didn't you know do you know what I mean
so that is okay that you have to give
credit to something like that but
there's another thing which is this
which is moral courage so you have the
physical courage and you have the moral
courage moral courage to speak what is
true and so with someone like myON or
someone like fresh and fit what I would
say to them brother with all due respect
like recently there was some kind of
thing where a woman I didn't even watch
it but I was told about it she was
attacking the prophet us yeah yeah and
and he didn't say anything so I would
say this is lacking in moral courage now
I'm not saying you're a coward maybe you
just had the wrong idea about it we're
not going to throw you under the buff
like that Myra but what we're saying is
that the next step for the true rights
of Passage for you to be a real man from
all perspectives not just from the
perspective of Islam from virtue ethnics
times from Aristotle's times from the uh
Babylonian times uh the Africans the
Asians the Chinese everyone would say
speak the
truth uh Malcolm X if you don't if you
don't stand up for something you'll fall
for anything anything for it's well
known in all societies that this is what
it takes to be a man so forget about the
body count Sor to say this is Bo kids
Stu how many yeah how many women you can
get and bag and put in the bed and bend
her over and give her some money she
don't love you she don't even care uh
she's just doing it from fame or money
or whatever prostitute most of these
people in fresh in prison sorry to say
they're escorts they are escorts so they
are prostitutes and I guess the ultimate
testy not the judge uh bravery if we
wanted to we could go to the escort for
services and we could call for four
escorts and they can come and sit here
we can pretend to have the upper hand on
them it wouldn't really mean anything
because they're not they're not
formidable opponents they're worthless
opponents they're worthless opponents so
it's actually the meaning to be in a
place and okay you're attacking some
woman that's basically a prostitute
about her job you need to help this
woman you need to take her out instead
of you know bringing some prostitutes
and go go go head-to-head with some some
some good idea we should do that's
that's actually a good idea like you
don't know but the woman
that you can to to call them and that'd
be a great stream yeah be the
process go we'll get some women in the
doll on the that fresh and food welome
the BR we have to but what I'm saying is
that we need to now recalibrate what it
means to be a man yes and it's it's fine
bro the society has changed our
perspectives on these things and what it
means to be a real man is to be brave
and what it means to be brave is to be
physically Brave and to be morally Brave
these are the two things I have to give
you credit for the debates you did on on
on Palestine because I think that's the
ultimate test right now of moral bravery
and people who are willing to stand up
for what's very clearly genocide and not
warn man most people choose to stay
silent especially people in my world of
streaming in the influencer people they
know what's going on off camera they
will speak about like the atrocities but
because they want the brand deals and
they want to be able to work with
managers they will stay silent about
something that that's in my opinion
worse than the Holocaust and what
especially what we learned in school and
then Zan I want to ask you that was a
very detailed answer yeah and I don't
want to throw my under the bus cuz I
think he's a nice no he he speaks about
all this stuff we want to bring him into
our fold yeah we really want him to be
part of our team we want him he has Slam
in his heart he's a clever guy you you
you saw something of his he's got he's
written a book or something hasn't he
why women deserve less so he's got an
intelligent mind you know honestly it's
a great title you can see you can know
[Laughter]
got no but I'm saying we don't want to
thr the start the bus but you can see
I've seen him speak a few times he's a
very intelligent young man we would just
want to tweak him a little bit because I
think he's in the wrong
and we want we want him to be part of
our you know our family we want him to
be closer to us that's what we want
bring back on De that's it that's what
we want zisha what is your definition or
of being a real
man I think the the definition of a real
man don't talk about me yet
on in this day it's it's what you're
saying where youve got genocide taking
place and people can't uh voice out
people can't speak out on the other hand
you've got people on road they they're
involved in gangs and they think they
have access that that specific area
belongs to them they think that's
bravery you've got people that think are
making this money that's
bravery I
think nowadays the ultimate and the test
of
bravery and and some people we see these
people at s's Corner as well and we
discuss with them and we say look BR
like you you're pretty much a Muslim
like what's stopping you yeah I met one
today yeah and he's I don't know maybe
it's I don't I don't think I can do it
it's this for me that's that's the sign
of Bravery that in an age where
believing in God is seemed or is made to
seem foolish that in a in a day and age
where alcohol fish like drugs
promiscuity is arm it's common it's
something that children as young as six
and seven are exposed to Aral
pornography but you ins a conservative
lifestyle conservative in terms of
principles of Islam that that's what I
mean by conservative and despite what
people are saying oh you're backwards or
you're barbarians or you're this or
you're stopping your child from doing
this and you stay firm because you know
like the prophecies that we've discussed
you know what's to come and that's
what's telling of a man a man is able to
look 10 years ahead and plans for his
family whilst women not all of them they
tend not to look that far ahead their
vision is a bit less and that's why the
union is very important because it it
complement each other very well so for
us in this day and age holding firm to
the Rope of Allah yeah I think that as
Islam tells us that's what's telling of
a man that a time will come that holding
on to Islam will be like holding on to a
burning cender in your hand that's a man
somebody that can hold on to a sender
and Cole that's a man somebody that can
say no to a woman like yfam said when
she came to him and somebody says no and
that's that's what I would even say
that's that's what I would say as well
when you're on streams and you got we
know the S DMS and this and that you say
no to that Pur that's that's a man
somebody yeah somebody when they're in
front of ruler they know they're going
to be canceled they know they're going
to be Shadow banned principally they say
you know what I'm going to say this
because that's the right thing to do
that's man can I ask you though is there
some sort of Bravery in not telling the
truth because if I had not telling the
truth two years ago when the lies about
Co were happening or when the lies about
the election were happening if I had
stayed silent I'd be able to make much
more money and then like we were talking
about earlier said sorry i' would be
able to to make even more money for for
my family and you said the most
important thing Ali is to provide for
your family in the immediate time would
it not be brave to put aside my moral
dignity said okay you know what what's
more important is is my family let me
let me tell the truth that over a slower
time scale you know why this is this is
where comes into it this is our problems
all about problems in the world tie back
to the oness of cour everything mention
anything I'll tie back to that the fact
that we know risk what God provides us
I'm not just talking about money yeah
the things that God Almighty gives us to
understand that except this is such a
beautiful concept that when I was not a
Muslim I didn't really understand it
when I became Muslim understood it but
you to say the truth because you are
relying one Allah is the one that
provides for you you need to understand
this close you do not provide for
yourself Allah is the one that's
providing for you so when you understand
that concept and believe that in in the
uniqueness the oness of God Almighty and
that he's provided for you you would say
me speaking the truth the factors are
not in the hands of my enemies they are
the ones that decide how much money
comes into my pocket or what blessings
God give is given to me it's God when
you do that this is when you find a true
freedom because you're not in the
shadows of if I done that or did this if
I didn't speak um this wouldn't happen
we don't believe that we believe and
this is what toas that to have having
trust that God will take care of you
this is such a beautiful concept that's
why when you look at I'm not going to
mention nam in the vide who are chasing
the world and the woman Etc their
purpose is limited our purpose is
unlimited our purpose is greater than
than this world you trying to say yeah
can I have
a I wish music wasn't Haram cuz you
could be a good
rapper still do with n let me know if
you want
to featuring
Al yes on the way to Mecca yeah so the
point is this bro when your when your
focus is limited when I was not a Muslim
my focus was limited girls that's what I
knew girls partying clubing here but
that's limited so when your vision is
unlimited like I said Allah is provided
that's why for you you made that
decision if I'm mistaken before you came
to Islam yeah good that shows you that's
whatab said some people if they at this
as the disbelievers if they came to
Islam the quality that you had look how
is beautified you further when you've
come to Islam because you've already had
that concept of no I will speak the
truth and Allah say this in the Quran
speak the truth even if it's against
yourself or your kin yeah so to uphold
that bro you did that as a disbeliever
let alone you're a Believer now imagine
if as a disbeliever you had that moral
concept yeah imagine what you can do
today so this is what you should stick
to Bro Allah is the one that provides
for us don't think if I do this and I do
that and this one no no no if you put
your trust in Allah bro Allah will take
care of all your Affairs this is why I
tell everybody W the effort that you put
into Instagram make up this carard this
look this that W if you gave 20% of the
effort that you put on to all of those
stuff to your lord to
Allah Allah will take care of all your
Affairs that's why I say fix your
affairs with Allah and Allah will fix
your affairs with the people and with
yourself that is the focus we need to
have which we don't have you got girls
makeup this that why cuz the concept is
what they are thinking if I beautify
myself I would get I would get a husband
or a guy yeah and we're seeing the
following yeah we believe sneer that a
woman who says I fear Allah and I will
cover myself and I will not even sh my
face argument say Allah will find her
somebody on the other side of the earth
that will come to her doorstep why
because we believe Allah is the one not
committing sins that I'm going to find
it so all I believe bro sure all of
these issues go back to if we truly
understood who Allah is put our Reliance
on him had had trust in him rather than
what I can do like the Hadi of the
Prophet peace be upon Him of the man
came with a camel and he didn't tie his
camel he said why you not tying a camel
he said I'll put my trust in God he said
tie your camel then put your trust in
God today we have a phenomena of not
only to tie your camel you have killed
your camel your camel is dead and then
you're like okay I've tried everything
now let me put my trust in God all
relates back to that but everything
relates back to not believe in Allah
enough and having enough T okay but
besides speaking the truth after I
became a Muslim um I rejected 15 I was
offered 15 to20 million a year to to
gamble on stream thank you would that
not have been was there is there not
some sort of righteousness at accepting
that deal no that would what if I took
that money and I gave it away to people
no no Allah only accepts that it's pure
yeah so Allah accepts only that is pure
we can people come and say you know if I
won the the lottery find in this look if
it comes from Haram Allah will never put
bar in that that would destroy you and
destroy everything around you but if you
come with pure let me tell you something
if you put Allah first meaning for
example you said no to that why because
it destroys people's lives how can I
make a living do you know I know people
who committed suicide because of
gambling how am I going to go to bed put
my head on my pillow knowing five people
just killed theel because the money that
they're supposed to provide for their
family has gone to some dirt bag who is
betting yeah or bet shop owner yeah so
to to to us that that's why when you ask
the question why are Muslims not
performing as well because to us we're
not about um oppressing and how we can
opportunistically take from people and
and that's what the world is doing they
don't care about anybody it's all about
me and Allah will destroy you but if you
put Allah first have Halal money even if
it's 202 W you will see the came that
the moment from your death till you die
Allah will make sure all that money in
your bank goes to good causes so to me
bro it's just having that trust in God
that Allah will take care of you and
this is this concept that we build up
what you s the question have to change
the battery can you hold that for one
second we have to change the battery go
ahead go ahead yeah so just building up
what you say about man we've heard today
we've heard a lot about speech let just
pae that though because Ali just made a
point I didn't want to lose the track
just hold that so what was saying is it
revers to the ey of the
Quran Allah is the guardian of the
righteous that if a person is righteous
Allah save this is Allah guaranteeing I
will be your guardus and because Allah's
created this machine Allah knows what's
good for it what's bad for it you you
and I we don't get to decide so if a
gambling contract comes and that's not
good for us that's not going to be good
there's what you might think it's that
illusion that oh I can do this and I can
do that but who gets to decide us in our
limited kind of understanding because we
have the pixel Allah is a picture and
Allah's given us morality by looking at
the whole picture yeah and we have only
a small pixel and we're trying to you
know say okay maybe it's like this or
maybe it's like that but our machine is
not designed to live with gambling with
alcohol with drugs with sexual
promiscuity why because Allah has
forbidden it what's your religion would
it be that on the on the one hand
Allah's forbidden all these things and
on the other hand that yeah it's all
right he can do it but uh I look you're
doing something good with it that would
be one of the religions that of course
we're trying to kind of warn people
against because if Allah's created
everything he knows everything and you
know everything you know he's given us a
coherent system then we can't say yep
the system works there but here you know
what it's not going to work in the
economic side like I I know no it's you
follow what Allah says and yes in the
short run you may not necessarily see it
by like putting a diesel in a petrol car
like gambling to a Muslim doesn't make
any sense even gambling to non-muslims
ultimately look at Society now because
of increased gambling alcohol and
because of a lack of objective morality
that's why the society is in the dec
decadent St it's in because it's going
further away from the laws of God and
you know that this is a beautiful lineup
because the question was what makes a
man right and we talked a lot about the
idea of like speaking um truth to
oppression or truth to like whatever it
is that you're facing um that is an
instantaneous thing that you do like you
can speak truth in the life of maybe
once maybe one time in your life as a
man you have to speak truth against
yourself however I believe if we when we
say expanding the idea what it means to
be man something you do on a consistent
basis now you were saying this so
beautifully Allah has designed us if we
think about when Allah creates man the
first time and the angel say are you
going to create a creation that's going
to cause chaos on earth right and Allah
says prostrate and then prostrate and
then he ask the Angels name the things
and they can't name the things Adam
names the things he names creation
it's inherent so being a man in my
language Gala call it and mu is a
caretaker right and we know in the Quran
Bak what caretaking isif to meaning
being a man is inherent to build a human
being meaning the caretaking so when you
are uh avoiding gambling your CTIC when
you're avoiding promiscuity you CTIC you
cultivate the land you're cultivating
the soul you're cultivating society and
that's what it means to be a man a man
means to be consistent in chake and
choosing the right thing over the the
wrong thing and I think that's also we
need what it means to be a human being
and that's this one happy if you know
this Allah um the prophet told us that
the man is the caretaker of the family
the woman is the caraker of the house
and you know
and so uh every U every she every
Shepherd is responsible for his flock
yeah and yeah and the woman is
responsible for her flock yeah and this
is why so interesting in the Arabic
language rajul is not only it's not
always specific to the
gender sometimes Raju can also be
attributed to a female in the terms of
like the way she behaves because of
those qualities and this is something I
wanted to always say there's a problem
when we look at gender and when we look
at sexuality we looking at through the
West lens because the way sexuality is
understood
internationally it's far more stretched
so for example this happened to me it's
a story my dad is African right and I
grew up in Germany one time I'm chilling
and my friends are coming and laughing
at I what SP it's like yo we saw you bad
what so what he was holding someone else
and he holding a man's head your dad is
day right and was laugh let me I was
like yo in Germany I but it's Germany
yeah in Germany so I'm like bro like
it's that so I went to my dad F years
later down the line I realized in
African society in alic society he told
out two men to hold hands because
sexuality is far more expensive than
this restrictive uh uh view of sexuality
that is um connected to cons um
capitalism right because the
capitalistic idea of sexuality is the
workforce we talked about women in the
workforce we talked about prostitution
all of these things are in hinged and
attached to capitalism now if two men or
for example uh roomie right there's this
one gay academic in in America he was
reading roomie a poet a persal poet and
he was saying based upon that based upon
the way R was talking about his friends
R was gay but if you know anything about
Persian um poetry and the sensibilities
of the Persians love a platonic love
that you exert towards man doesn't
necess say that you g it's just a
different way of viewing a man right so
R would talk about a man's beautiful
eyes R would talk about shi's beautiful
your beautiful hair and your beautiful
eyes but it's not in in a sense how
Western people would understand
sexuality so again this idea of like
what makes a man are traits that you can
find in other entities as well but they
are inherent with within the back and
sorry for going so deep and academic
with so passionate by I like your idea
about them you know the the fact that a
man is caretaker I think that's a that's
a powerful idea it's also chanic
idea you know yeah certainly the
caretaking is a part of it you takeing
care of your woman but and your children
and stuff like that but also I like what
Zan said about self-restraint yeah
because this in in in virtue ethics
terms this used to be called Temperance
there's a word for it Temperance is when
you can control your behavior you have
restraint actually heathenism is
opposite to that so like the the
earliest civilization or understandings
of what it means to be a good person a
virtuous person whether a man or woman
is that you have control over yourself
you're not a glutton you not eat too
much you like what we do
today me but or like what do you call it
um you're not just saying what you want
to say you're not impulsive you're not
whatever this is called temperance
now heathenism is actually antithetical
to Temperance because heathenism when
you're doing what you want and having
intercourse with whatever woman you want
and all that kind of stuff it's you're
effectively not you're not actually
controlling yourself at that not what
Destiny promes yeah yeah so as heis I'm
s you see his body that guy you see his
body you see his face you see his
behavior you see his wife you see his
relationships everything is broken down
and it's because of a lack of temperance
a lack of virtue of effective he's a non
virtuous person these are examples of
trash Gutter People someone said he
Destiny doesn't play Devil's Advocate
Destiny is literally Devil's Advocate
yeah I mean I saw I just I was scrolling
and I saw a picture of of a man with his
shirt off and he had you know nothing to
show for himself like physically and he
had he has nothing to show for himself
intellectually as we saw as well he's a
nice guy he's a nice guy to some people
what you know when I saw what he's
saying about the genocide that's not
very nice bro well when he said that I
mean yeah this is the second time I've
ever seen him say anything and uh it
just to be honest I V the guy has no you
should debate him yeah well okay come
debate no problem I ready I'm I'm ready
to fight in debate anybody send me
location okay okay I I he a homosexual I
was no Des say he's homosexual is you
yeah I would I don't have any
discrimination of
humilation Who Wants To Be A there's no
problem
what's he going to talk to me about uh
you know what's this area of
specialism no problem but the point I'm
making to you is that these are
archetypes of failure in the modern
world no let's be honest like the W come
on he likes dying his hair balloon no
forget about that I'm saying that what
do you have to show for yourself as a
man what do I have to respect yes are
successful stream what do I have to
respect about someone like this guy do
you know what I mean what is it what is
it to be a stream that's he talks
fast untalent individuals you know we're
living in an age where untalented people
can have notoriety that's the TRU isn't
that the sign of the end
times the knowledge will be quiet and
the ignorant will be speaking the about
Des do yeah he's
part is he the job no but
notor will be TR untalented untalented
like there's nothing there like at least
with Kim Kardashian or or this fers
they're untalent something there well
yeah no no they're untalented but they
may have beauty or something with ch but
we're talking about an individual bereft
of talent and aesthetic Beauty so what
do you have to offer what are you
putting on the table for me I mean why
do I have to respect you because the
thing is a man is never going to respect
a man that can't challenge him or impose
consequence on him physically or
intellectually that's the truth I'm
never going to give him too much respect
I might feel sorry for him sympathy
that's the only emotion disgust that's
another emotion I feel
no honestly these are the kind of I look
at them I feel disgusted I feel a a
bedazzlement s there you go he's got
something to for you then isn't
he attribute no but what I'm saying is
that these are archetypes of failure
frankly I'm being honest with you bro
the Western tradition is not like the
Western virtue tradition it um had
things like magnanimity had things like
Temperance things like forbearance
things like compassion no money no
material it's only a world view that can
make make you think like that a
worldview that I've got better things
coming who was one of the great sahabis
right he just became Muslim like
yourself imagine this just became Muslim
got married he had his
wife and he was about to go to war but
she was calling him to the bed she was
calling him to the bed so he want to
have sex with her so to say he said you
know what I'm young guy he had sex with
then he went to war yeah he he had sex
with then he went to war he was killed
in the war
and that we we believe he became a mat
and the angels washed him up can I can I
can I exp this said I saw can expr after
sexual
relation he didn't he didn't have time
so after sexual relation after you have
ring married and you have sexual
intercourse with your
wife you have to wash all your B so we
do Min Purity is a full yeah yeah you
can say
full bigo cuz I want to keep this
conversation also very intelligent
because we don't want to play into the
tropes because this idea is that
martydom with the Muslims is like this
barbaric unthinking people who blow ups
themselves martydom actually if you
think about from the quranic perspective
is something very difficult that's why
Allah criticizes the people who do not
go to the battle because it's difficult
to do so it's not something maor s if
you turn back yeah it's difficult to
difficult to Leave the World Behind it's
idea that every every Muslim can just go
and blow up themselves these are the
crazy people that have actually we're
not we're not blow up just to talk about
people that are have actually something
to luse and decide to go against their
own fear and love for the for life and I
think that's something that we also have
to really talk about because sometimes
we play into those tropes of 100% but
but on the other hand I was very
surprised cuz I saw a recent thing I
don't know if you guys saw this but Sam
Harris is an atheist here he was having
this discussion with a couple of other
guys one of them was like another
atheist and he was they were talking
about the military apparatus in the
Quran and Sunnah and and the guy says
something affective says something to
behold he was he was praising his and
they're atheism and you can see Sam
Harris is not he's always been a Critic
of Islam he didn't like what this guy
was saying but he didn't want to refute
it because he kind of silently
acknowledged the truth in it militarily
bro and strategically if you have a a a
group of people that actually in a sense
prefer to die but imagine The Bravery
that's going to come from their mind
imagine how far they're going to take it
how else can you explain the fact that
Islam spread in the way it did no other
religion spread in the way that Islam
spread none Christianity it was
Constantine okay who became a Christian
and then he spread it by force Islam
wasn't like that bro they had to go and
invade
Nations and for them imagine like you
got a small group of people yeah small
group of people comparatively 5,000
people going to the Roman Empire
fighting them when they're 10 to1 ratio
they they're losing 10 to1 ratio maybe
even 20 to1 but no one does that but
that's The Bravery that's required to
overtake and to conquer bro that bravery
cannot come from just okay let's let's
uh tune our sympathetic nervous systems
and uh tame our amigdalas it's not like
that this is a bravery that has to come
from something higher than that BR which
is where it's coming from is the higher
ethic which is bro we're willing to die
for this cuz we believe if you die as a
mar you'll be provided for that you'll
be alive you'll be this you'll be that
you have to admit militarily a people
that believe in this theology bro are
and if they're ready if they're ready to
fight they're going to be the most
dangerous people even sorry even Robert
Green said this himself you know Rob
Green 48 Laws he said that the one who's
willing to commit suicide has the
initiative this is a one of the rules of
power yeah I'm not saying we want to
commit suicide I'm saying that you're
willing to fight to the extent where you
could die the Willing the one who's
willing to commit suicide has the
initiative which
means yeah in a way he had the
initiative but even him bro when his
ideology died he killed himself do you
get it but in Islam it's not like that
do you know when he died the whole
movement died because it wasn't
something that is like
transcendental but with Islam it's
different because it's not
con is to do with the heart Hereafter
and stuff purpose is greater than this
life that's the isue you get it that's
why the people that purpose is this life
you see what they do sleep around this
that the purpose is great events and
that's why that's this what this doesn't
add add adds to the the non-muslim they
do not understand the concepts alien to
them to ask even like the concept which
I fell in love with with Islam was the
concept of loving for the sake of Allah
I didn't understand what that meant I
was like what does that mean why do I
have to love speak for the S of Allah
can I love him because he's a good
person because I'm just a good person
then I realize as human beings we always
have terms and conditions there's always
a there's something there what am I
gaining from something there you say but
when you think about the concept of
doing it for the sa of Allah it is so
beautiful and it will solve so many
problems of the non-muslims if they had
this concept because everyone in today
societ is doing what what can I gain out
of the other transactional relationship
everything is people always tell me to
cut off I have a friend named neon he's
he younger Muslim stre and I I I say I
always make sure that that I'm I'm there
and I respond to him I'm checking up
with him he's my musim brother
regardless of like how he like changes
the reputation and what he does like
that's my musim brother and love for the
sake of Allah exactly sake of Allah
means what bro it's transaction meaning
the follow if you come to me one day and
say I'm in a really bad position can you
L me £5,000 I'll be like okay I have it
there you go the next day you come and
argue and say you st swearing at me you
st swearing at me start swearing at me I
would never ever say you know what BR I
wish I never gave him that 5,000 I wish
I never help sneak up because my reason
of doing that was what I done it for the
pleasure of God I don't give a damn if
you're going to slap me in my fa face or
are you going to humiliate me or
whatever for that matter yeah I said
I've done that for the sake of Allah no
problem and there's an ay in the Quran
why when Abu Bakr his daughter was
slandered and AA the prophet's wife yeah
Abu Bak is her father she was standed
against that she committed adul this was
a big Stander Sur was sent down yeah and
Abu Bakr used to give some money to a
specific individual and that individual
was one of the ones who started the
rumor and abaka stopped giving the money
money and Allah sent down Revelation say
do not do this basically carry on giving
why because it was for the sake of God
not I'm going to stop it now because he
did listen to me but today we do is what
everything is transaction you know how
fake that is bro I've lived that life it
makes me sick when I'm around people who
are like okay why is this person I'm
doing this brother we do it for the sake
of Allah and when you understand this
concept it's so beautiful because it's
like I'm not calling that brother so I
can get some but that person like
brother it's just for the sake of I'm
here for the sake of Allah inshallah and
this is something you need to work on
it's not something that you you are
given it's something that you get and if
you look at today's society everyone's
selfish absolutely nobody about anybody
bro people are the guys died on the flo
recorded social media what he's talking
about is very true and actually
psychological Studies have been done on
this it's actually a phenomena called
the diffusion of
responsibility in the west it's it's
high it's on steroids to thing what is
diffusion responsibility is that you
diffuse the responsibil need to someone
else so for example there's a lot of
sexual assaults that happen in the west
what we call stranger rape or stranger
sexual assault or stuff like that yeah
what we find is that people don't want
to get involved because they believe in
individualism the religion of the West
is liberalism now and as part of
liberalism this idea of individualism
individualism is this idea that you
yourself really you know what's best for
yourself do what's best for yourself you
are in charge of yourself it's all about
yourself effectively you are the master
the individual is king that's what
individual is yeah so because that's the
idea the person makes a a rational
Choice Theory or calculus he starts
calculating the situation says why
should I get involved this woman here is
getting hurt or this man here is getting
beaten in the street if I get involved I
might lose my life I might lose my
health what do I have to gain from that
what's the utility what's the utility in
that so this phenomena of diffusion of
responsibility this phenomena of
diffusion of responsibility makes
everyone selfish effectively if you like
for example if we go to Africa right now
yeah in any part of subsaharan Africa
any part of Africa that as a continent
any part any country you like if someone
gets into a fight in a village or in a
city for the most part everyone's going
to get R and try to stop it someone gets
into a fight in London bro I'm sorry to
say do you think someone's get involved
no one's getting involved because it's
like why should I it's not my business
I'm going to hurt myself because it's
not it's not a communal they don't have
a communal wiring they have an
individualistic wiring and that's what's
destroy in their societies this idea of
a diffusion of responsibility so what
I'm saying is actually and it's so
ironic because being individualistic
ironically is against the individual
being selfish is ironically not in the
self-interest of the person it's more
self-sufficient to pay attention of the
community yeah because for for example
and this is in most self-help books and
stuff here even nowadays which is that
think when win think reciprocity if I
help this guy if I help him if I'm
generous and stuff like that
you know the Hindus and the Easter
tradition is K what goes around comes
around there's a degree of Truth in that
notion in fact as there's Arab proverb
which is in line with
Islam that you are rewarded with what
you give effectively yeah so the point
is if you give off to different people
goodness generosity Hospitality respect
bravery sacrifice you'll get that back
but if you're a selfish person doesn't
want to get involved doesn't want to do
this think about yourself this and that
then don't don't complain actually BR in
this country in this country you got I
of my mom had a neighbor you know and
the the the house was smelling bad the
house just SW about so the police came
and opened up saw the woman was dead
inside wow they said why is the woman
dead inside oh because the the kids
didn't come and see her why because
there isn't an emphasis on being good to
your
parents imagine it's so it's so horrible
that would carees bro it be shocking
it's shocking almost anywhere else in
the world but in this country bro like
imagine someone care about their mom so
much or their dad whatever so much that
they died in the house you mentioned
this but what he's mentioned is and he's
mentioned it very well and he stuck in
my head it was that human rights H this
is the Bedrock of this society and human
rights is all to do with what you ow yes
these are my rights this is what I need
to have but which of the human rights
articles deals with responsibility yeah
human responsibility yeah about what you
owe to somebody else that all to do with
what you've what you owe what you owe
and that's what he's saying it then
leads to individualism materialism I
mean even look at the um the inheritance
system your Islamic inheritance system
is the only one that sets aside an
amount for your parents it even
considers your parents and here when
we're talking about what Ali saying your
parents when they reach a certain age
they're of no utility to you there was a
sketch show where he said you know I
went home I saw my mom she he a scet he
was joking you know she wasn't cooking
she was sleep she wasn't cleaning she
wasn't well so that's when I decided
there's no use for her so I just uh you
know but obviously there was a laugh and
this and that because people didn't
expect it to go that way but that that
is literally what happens you're
literally sent to a care home to live
the rest of your life why because the
kids are supposed to you know be the
best that you can enjoy life you know
pleasure over pain which is what
liberalism is the again another Bedrock
of liberalism that if pleasure outweighs
pain it's good if pain outweighs
pleasure then it's bad now this is what
the Quran says as well have you seen the
people that have taken the desires as
their Lords so all of these things are
the bedro of the western civilization
and that's why you see well and that's
it you know so to cut you off but on
this point J know's ironic about that as
well is the more you chase pleasure
ironically the more you get pain yeah
right this is one of the things I was
reading in that book here you know it's
the case in fact that is very Buddhist
Buddhist as well um um but in fact
Socrates Socrates in the helenistic
period or The Classical period I should
say Socrates I was a prr experience but
he was socres but socres said that
basically pain and pleasure are two
sides of the same qu that if if you
focus too much on Pleasure you end up
getting pain so if you yeah that's what
you mentioned so very interesting that
pain pleasure is like a shadow the more
you move towards it the move the more
moves away from you the ones who try and
seek pleasure are most likely the ones
who get least pleasure yeah because the
thing is if you're going for the
short-term solution you want to
ejaculate you want to eat the food you
want to diss that whatever no problem
we're not saying you shouldn't ejaculate
or eat the food whatever but if that's
the if that is your epitome of pleasure
bro I'm sorry it's fleeting I just ate
this food now okay I ate this food I was
hungry before and now I'm not hungry
anymore but that's it it's it's I'm not
going to remember 3 days from now what
kind of food I just ate now frankly it's
a it's a fleeing memory I don't even
remember what I ate 3 days ago because
it's not really that it's not the level
of pleasure is not to the point where
it's changed my life like that so how
many times have I ejaculated in my life
at
[Laughter]
least is that the best the West can
offer me bro what What can you offer me
let's be real for a second yeah what can
what can the West offer me so I say I'm
ready now let's say I don't want to live
a religious life a restricted life a
disciplined life I don't want to live
that now I want to be a Westerner for a
couple couple of weeks let's say for the
sake of AR bring me in bring me in
Destiny bring me in myON bring me in to
one of your hes a prostitutes and and
your and your escorts show me what you
could do for me so what are you going to
do you get me a couple holes I'm going
to do what I want to do with them all
right fine I'm going sorry to say it I'm
people cruit I'm going to eat some food
I'm going to drink some alcohol wake up
with a hangover headache vomit in the
toilet sorry to say y I'm going to put
inject some heroin in my body you know
what I'm saying and then have a
withdrawal impact afterwards cuz the
body keeps schore and that's the name of
a book by the way it's called the body
keeps school by uh van uh van cook he
wrote a book called the body keeps
schore there's no such thing as a
substance that you put into your body
for pleasure that's not going to come
back and take pain from you is it the
body will keep track if you if you get a
high from uh from ecstasy or from speed
or from uh what do you call it a heroin
that means you're going to get a crash
you're going to go below the Baseline
you're going to get you're going to get
sick from that to all the that's what
I'm saying so no problem I'm going to
take some a couple of drinks I'm going
to take a couple of heroin I'm going to
have sex with a couple of hoes I'm going
to you know go out going to cut this B
about go out just do this good clubing
so loud some music is so loud I can't
even hear anything anything I can't even
see anything and the lights are flashing
oh okay what now I've ejaculate I might
I I've eat have eating food uh what what
can you offer me show me what I want
more now I'm hungry I'm hungry for for
something more bro you want is more how
comes if you knew what makes me happy
you guys are the most depressed yeah
exactly how comes according to for
magazine and the World Health
Organization the most depressed
countries in the world that the Western
countries know I want to know that if
you guys know so well how to make me
happy how comes your people on the
anti-depressant how how
comes how comes that we have discovered
now from the most longitudinal studies
known to man for example the Harvard
study Harvard study very longitudinal
study for 30 years that the best thing
that promotes satisfaction in life is
Human Relationships they're meaningful
things and all there's a study bro man
University
2019 Germany yeah bro listen to this
study and you can download this if you
don't believe me the effects of Oneness
belief of Life satisfaction listen the
but you know what it said the most
satisfied people these are non-muslim
right in this the most satisfied people
in the world according to this study
2019 not written by m written by Laura
Tobin and some other two thing most
satisfied people in the world
are Muslims they actually wrote the word
Muslims and they don't become Muslim
after realizing bro I'm saying that this
is the effects of oness beliefs of Life
satisfaction that's the name of the
study bro so what we're talking about
here the studies are you almost
unanimous in showing that your life of
heathenism leads to displeasure and
honia the opposite of pleasure and our
life of meaningfulness purposefulness
and so on so forth that's leading to
real satisfaction so why am I going to
live your life you go where you where
you got off for me ex I have sex I have
woman I have sex woman I can eat food
the Western world is thirsty for you for
me they are dying for they are dying for
Islam and then yeah I would I would say
like end on that note man like you know
the prophet said taking your looking not
looking after to your parents he said
may his face be robbed in dust may his
face be rubbed in dust may his face be
rubbed in dust for the one whose parents
reach old age and he doesn't look after
to them this is the biggest Bo K imagine
the one that looked after you and you
put him the cuz you want to go holiday
to wherever this is and you want to come
and tell us Islam you dying for Islam
and that's why one scholar said if the
non-muslims knew what we have Islam they
they will pick up they will pick up arms
to come and fight you for it if they
knew the contentment we have when we
talk about R having trust in God and
this that they pick up arms they'll get
arms to come and fight you for it they
don't know what we have you know because
Andel is content knowing coming from
that lifestyle well they don't know what
we have it's frustrating seeing that
that so many of these intellects are are
so close to realizing their studies
proving that Muslims are have the most
contentment I don't know if you ever
read the unibomber manifesto but he
talks about all the problems that you
just addressed back before technology
really took over I think he wrote it in
the 70s uh in ' 80s and he was talking
about how the the rise of Technology was
going to cause overs socialization we're
going to be too we're going to be
communicating with too many people and
not have a community aspect or
liberalism is going to it's a great reap
and he ended up mailing bombs to Harvard
professors and University professors for
cuz he was really disenfranchised and
they they put MK Ultra on his brain uh
he was a really smart person and he end
up going away to the woods and he wrote
this Manifesto saying how liberalism
over socialization and Technology was
just going to ruin the west and he was
pretty much right he predicted the rise
of social media he predicted the
predicted the rise of liberalism but he
never became Muslim he was he was
describing all the all the problems with
the west but he never got to the full
solution even though his IQ was
something like 170 he was one of the
smartest people he was teaching Harvard
classes he teaching University of class
when he was like 23 years old what do
you think is is the deciding factor that
takes those people who realize that
Muslims have that contentment what can
really help them push to that final step
to to take the Shahar and become a
Muslim I think and again if I if I may
just to add to and this is a beautiful
question um you're
asking the West has
tra and the tra are you a rever yes I
am Christian yeah the West has truma and
the West the truma stems from An Origin
that has nothing to do with Islam MH the
reason why the West becomes liberal if
in your historical the reason why the
West becomes liberal is because it's
preceding with centuries of tyranny MH
that has a a conception of religion yes
that has nothing to do with Islam so if
you go to a western person you tell the
religion they have trauma and they're
misanthropes they hate God because of
what the Catholic church has done and
fysal science as well because exactly so
what we dealing here we're dealing with
people we're telling them look come back
to religion but they're looking at us
and thinking we are Martin Luther or we
you know Thomas aquinus or they are
attributing our religiousness with their
own trauma that's right and I think what
we have to do in the D and this is why
I'm always very understanding sometimes
why a feminist not the feminist today
but the feminist perhaps the first way
of feminism where it exists is because
it goes against the very fabric of what
it means to be woman right the Muslims
never treated women EXA in a way where a
woman had to feel like protesting you
see the feminist is more misogynistic
than all the people that they yes it's a
a uniquely West the same thing with
sexuality it's a uniquely a western
problem but what I think we as Muslims
have to tell them is like look I
understand what you went through yeah
yeah but we not inviting you do this we
inviting you to the balanced way which
is Islam and people we need to
understand that first and then I believe
they could find the way to ISA when you
give D what's that final straw that gets
people to take the Shahara for those
people that are so close but can't de
yeah the CR de is um it's that human
contact because sometimes what what will
happen is when you're so fixated on
arguments and you're so fixated on the
nuts and the bolts of the things you
miss what actually makes us humor and
that's connection that's understanding
the the person and sometimes that's what
he is the the problem is not very
complex the problem will be something
like something happened in his life or
uh a perception that he has about
something so if you connect with
somebody as a human being not thinking
you know what he needs this argument or
he needs this and I can provide this and
that sometimes all he is is actually
taking a step back listening to him yes
and sometimes the question would be when
you're speaking to somebody not giving
them dawa first is asking where he needs
dawa so finding out where those gaps are
like so what will it take for you to
accept Islam like what are the tick
boxes oh no I need to see God and I
would need the scripture to be approved
like why the Quran is so what he is now
telling you in essence is he's giving
you a checklist yeah if you just follow
that checklist then that will be better
than you speaking at him for 45 minutes
this might even be a 20- minute
conversation where you're just talking
about the points that he wants answered
and sometimes just listening being there
as a human being as opposed to I'm going
to tell you now I'm your teacher now I'm
this so what's the issue that you have
Pro tell me let me hear it I think this
is the issue that's the issue like shell
says data give me data give me
information even when he's at home he's
he's got all of this data coming in he
said give me as much data and then from
that data he's able to extrapolate he's
able to kind of draw a pattern and say
okay this is where it's going we should
be doing the same thing as well
sometimes it's not let me do this and
that's the thing is because sometimes
what we're doing is we're developing
relationships you see somebody one week
you speak to him if he needs to go he
needs to go it's not like no no I must
now get you to convert no then I'll see
you next week bro there was one guy I
was speaking to bro I just remembered he
told me the date that his wife died and
that was very close to him I remember
that date and I just in a passing
comment I quoted it that
one he he said you've won my heart with
them the fact that you've remembered my
wife every week when he saw me
thereafter he was like he ignored
everybody
so that that's it's that human contact
it's that human concern and that that
transcends everything yeah no it's not
even that it's it's caring about the
person bro I gen there's a person in our
local area bro his English is not that
great but when he goes to somebody he
leans in and he's like look I truly have
concern for you and look just like a
drop of alcohol or you know a sip of
alcohol can have an effect on a person
Iman has like faith has an effect on the
believer IM should be emanating from
that believer like somebody we met today
as what he said look I get some good
energy from you and from that person and
this and that like some people can sense
this stuff like Iman should be
permeating from you and the only way
that's going to happen is if you put
your head this on the floor in front of
him and when you do that that's when he
says you know what now let me Elevate
him his head is down there let let me
Elevate that head in front of the people
now because he's humbled himself to me
then to everybody else then you are
somewhat but here in front of Allah
you're crying what man cries brother
don't cry and this and that companions
would cry it would be normal but cry in
front of who cry in front of Allah and
that's what makes you a man when you're
able to S to to to say you know what he
is the one he is the one he deserves he
deserves my about are you guys here
tomorrow yeah we we have to get going
anyway this is a perfect thing tomorrow
yeah in cuz tomorrow I'm free if you
guys just want to catch on I would love
to yeah let me know where you guys are
going to be let me get your
number okay yeah yeah we do have to get
going the restaurant was to close up I
would love to keep going for a long time
thank you so much everybody here uh to
J muhamed job again of course Al I
appreciate you all I didn't get that L
that would of course we got here I
couldn't do do thank you again my
driving over here this restaurant thank
you everybody here I appreciate it the
Warner of course come on man come on
come on come on man um by the way we
have a a a charity if you want to
perform as z c or even if you're not
Muslim we have project if project.org uh
you can give uh $2 and you'll give one
meal yesterday we raped $6,000 Mas
$6,000 so you guys we fed 3,000 people
alone in in yesterday's stream let's try
to let's see if we could double it today
so the link will be there I'm sure that
they could put it in the description
does this stream does it end like when
the live or do you put it off as videos
how do you oh I can send it to you if
you you would like what it what's it
called Rumble Rumble Rumble it's like
you you've never seen
Rumble conation like shout out to Robble
we have free speech over here I've been
banned for on YouTube for two years it's
very ref so if anyone put a video they
get trouble as well no you're fine
you're fine cuz when they promote you
you know you're okay if you you could be
able to post but we don't want to speak
too much about that cuz they might
that's besides the point uh thank you so
much for coming on robar told the
Muslims here I hope you stay steadfast
on the rest of Ramadan um and when you
get married you call us to your
W if you can
do over zo do do you have best men in in
Islam does that two witnesses no no you
have best brother wit you best brother
brother okay I got to Rel out all these
Pagan rituals that I was took me time I
can remember when I first came someone
was doing this I was like yeah and he
was like what you doing I don't know my
coach then my car had the blue
eye
okay he St this it's normal St you got
to help me all this don't wor it trust
me thank you again for coming out
everybody this I really enjoyed the
headline um I'll see you guys soon I'll
be should be back tomorrow bye guys